GOOD AFTERNOON IN RESPONSE TO
THE CLUB IN NINETEEN. EMERGENCY. AND TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES WE
MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS AND IT HERE TO SOCIAL
DISTANCING AND FACE COVERING
GUIDELINES IN COMPLIANCE WITH
THOSE ORDERS THE SENATE HAS MADE
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS WE ARE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HEARINGS IN THE
CAPITAL WITH SOME MEMBERS ABLE
TO PARTICIPATE REMOTELY TODAY
THE MEMBERS OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE
ARE HERE WILL BE HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM. THOSE PROVIDING
TESTIMONY BEFORE THE COMMITTEE
TODAY ARE PARTICIPATING REMOTELY
FOR REMOTE PARTICIPANTS PLEASE
MUTE YOUR PHONES OR COMPUTERS
THIS WILL GREATLY HELP IN THE
LEMONADE IN ANY ACOUSTIC
FEEDBACK I S. IT EVERY TIME YOU
WISH TO BE RECOGNIZED THAT YOU
USE THAT RAISE YOUR HAND FEATURE
IN THE PROGRAM EACH TIME YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK A POP UP
WINDOW WILL APPEAR ASKING IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO ADMIT IT PLEASE
SELECT ON MUTE BEFORE YOU BEGIN
SPEAKING OUR I. T. PERSONNEL
WILL PUT YOU BACK ON MUTE WHEN
YOU ARE DONE. ONCE RECOGNIZED TO
SPEAK PLEASE MAKE SURE YOU CAN
BE SEEN ON THE SCREEN STATE YOUR
NAME AND THEN YOU ARE READY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE TO ALLOW
THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TO THE HEARING ROOM TO THE
EXTENT THAT SOCIAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS ALLOW I WILL BE
USING A TELECONFERENCE RIVERS
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH
TO TESTIFY TODAY. IF YOU WISH TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT. PLEASE
CALL THE TOLL FREE NUMBER AND
ACCESS CODE. THAT IS POSTED ON
OUR WEB COMMITTEE WEBSITE AND I
WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW. THE NUMBER
TO CALL IS. EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO
NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX FOUR. AND
THE ACCESS CODE IS FIVE EIGHT
SIX THREE. NINE ONE SEVEN. FOR
DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW THE
TELECONFERENCES TO MARKS PLEASE
REFER TO THE SENATE AND OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WHEN WE MOVED
TO PUBLIC COMMENT YOU WILL BE
PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR TO DIAL
ONE THEN ZERO. PRESS THIS ONLY
ONE TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY. AS
AN OPERATOR WILL COME TO YOU
ASSIGN YOUR LINE NUMBER. AND
THIS CAN TAKE A LITTLE BIT. ONCE
YOU RECEIVE YOUR LINE NUMBER YOU
WILL WAIT IN THE QUEUE FOR THE
MODERATOR TO CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER. AT THAT TIME YOU WILL BE
ON MUTE IT AND YOU'RE NOW READY
TO ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY AND TO AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK. YOU MUST MUTE
THE DEVICE YOU WERE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY AND ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO
IS DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED
FROM THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE
OR HAVE YOUR THEIR CONNECTIONS
MUTED. NOW WE WILL BEGIN THE
HEARING. WELL BEFORE WE BEGIN
OUR DOCTOR BACK BILL WILL YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL TO
ESTABLISH QUORUM. BUT WE DON'T.
WE'LL DO IT LATER OKAY- OKAY
THIS IS THE SUBCOMMITTEE HEARING
WILL COVER ALL REMAINING
DISCUSSION ITEMS INCLUDING JAIL
OVERSIGHT PRISON INFRASTRUCTURE
AND TRANSPORTATION WE WILL HEAR
EACH ITEM FIRST AND THEN WE WILL
TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE END
ALL ISSUES WILL BE HELD OPEN
THERE WILL BE NO VOTES TAKEN
TODAY. WE WILL BEGIN WITH THESE-
ITEMS FOR DISCUSSION THE FIRST
ITEM IS ISSUE ONE. JAIL
OVERSIGHT AND WE'RE GOING TO
START WITH- WE'RE GONNA START
WITH THE- BSE C. ARE AND WILL BE
PRESENTING ON BEHALF OF THE
DEPARTMENT. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR THIS IS KATIE HOWARD THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE SEC
THREE COMMA YOU MISS HOWARD GOOD
TO SEE YOU TOO ALL I JUST WANNA
BE SURE THAT THAT THE COMMITTEE
IS AWARE WE THE PANELISTS RIGHT
NOW KFC ON THE SCREEN THAT HAS
THE HEARING ROOM ON IT SO I'M
LOOKING AT THE CAMERA BUT I
CAN'T SEE YOU. IS THAT OKAY NO
BECAUSE WE WELL WE CAN'T SEE YOU
EITHER SO THERE'S NO YOU CAN'T
OKAY I CAN SEE NAME OKAY STAND
BY FOR TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
THANK. YOU WE'LL- SEE.
I GUESS THAT WASN'T ALREADY. I
THINK THE THIRD. CAN YOU SEE IS
IT MISS HOWARD YES I CAN SEE YOU
NOW OKAY. THANK YOU AND- WE
CAN'T SEE YOU. WOULD YOU LIKE ME
TO WAIT YES PLEASE OUR.
I THINK WE'RE READY. OKAY AXLE
HEY WE CAN SEE YOU CAN YOU CAN
SEE US PERFECT THAT'S TERRIFIC
AND THE AUDIENCE OKAY ALREADY
OKAY THANK YOU. AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE AGAIN I'M KATIE
HOWARD THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE B. S. C. C. I AM HAPPY TO BE
HERE TODAY ALONG WITH MY
COLLEAGUE ALLISON GANTER TO TALK
ABOUT THE BSE SEES JAIL
INSPECTION RESPONSIBILITIES
WHICH ARE CORE TO THE BST SEES
MISSION. I'M GONNA GIVE A
OVERVIEW OF OUR JAIL INSPECTION
RESPONSIBILITIES AND TRY TO
COVER THE THINGS THAT THE
COMMITTEE STAFF HAS ASKED US TO
TOUCH ON AND THEN OF COURSE
WE'RE HAPPY TO TAKE YOUR
QUESTIONS. SOME OF THE PENAL
CODE SETS FORTH REQUIREMENTS THE
REQUIREMENT THAT THE BSP C.
INSPECT ALL COUNTY DETENTION
FACILITIES BOTH. ADULT AND
JUVENILE AND BECAUSE OF
STATUTORY CHANGES THAT WERE MADE
LAST YEAR AS WELL AS ADDITIONAL
BUDGET RESOURCES THAT WERE
PROVIDED. WE NOW INSPECT EACH
FACILITY DANIEL. PRIOR TO TWENTY
TWENTY ONE THOSE VISITS THOSE
INSPECTIONS WERE. AT LEAST ONCE
OVER A TWO YEAR CYCLE SO WE'RE
NOW ABLE TO INSPECT FACILITIES
MORE FREQUENTLY. IN ADDITION WE
NOW HAVE THE AUTHORITY TO
CONDUCT UNANNOUNCED INSPECTIONS
AND THAT'S AN IMPORTANT NEW TOOL
AND ONE THAT I EXPECT WILL COME
INTO PLAY IN RESPONSE TO ISSUES
LIKE THE ONES THAT HAVE BEEN
RAISED IN THE IN THE RECENT.
AUDIT ABOUT SAN DIEGO COUNTY.
PRIOR TO LAST YEAR'S B. C. P. WE
HAD EIGHT INSPECTORS RESPONSIBLE
FOR COMPLETING THE INSPECTIONS.
REPORTS AND PROVIDING EXTENSIVE
ONGOING TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE FOR
OVER FIVE HUNDRED FIFTY
DISABILITIES AND I'M I'M SURE
THAT MANY TO REMEMBER AS WE
TALKED ABOUT THIS AT SOME LENGTH
LAST YEAR. WE ARE SO PLEASED TO
BE ADDING ANY ADDITIONAL
INSPECTORS AND SOME ANALYTICAL
STAFF AS WELL. TO MEET THE
REQUIREMENTS OF OUR ENHANCED
INSPECTION PROCESS WHICH THE
GOVERNOR DIRECTED US TO DEVELOP
IN TWENTY TWENTY. SO WE'RE VERY
APPRECIATIVE THAT THE GOVERNOR
AND THE LEGISLATURE HAVE
PROVIDED ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
FOR THIS VITALLY IMPORTANT WORK.
I WANT TO GIVE A VERY QUICK
OVERVIEW OF HOW THE INSPECTION
PROCESS WORKS- TITLE FIFTEEN
SETS FORTH THE REGULATIONS FOR
THE OPERATION OF- COUNTY
FACILITIES AND TITLE TWENTY
FOUR. ADDRESSES PHYSICAL PLANT
ISSUES. WHEN IT COMES TO THE IN
PERSON INSPECTIONS WE BEGIN WITH
THE REVIEW OF POLICIES ON MANY
OF OUR REGULATIONS ARE WHAT'S
KNOWN AS PERFORMANCE BASED AND
IT DIRECTS THE AGENCY TO HAVE A
POLICY ON A VARIETY OF DIFFERENT
KINDS OF. SUBJECTS THAT HAVE TO
DO WITH THE OPERATION OF THE
FACILITY SO WE BEGIN WITH
REVIEWING THE DOCUMENTS THAT
HAVE BEEN PROVIDED BOTH POLICY
AND SUPPORTING DOCUMENTS TO
DETERMINE IF THE LOCAL. AGENCY
IS IN COMPLIANCE WITH TITLE
FIFTEEN OR TITLE TWENTY FOUR AS
THE CASE MAY BE. WE CAN DO A
PHYSICAL INSPECTION OF THE
FACILITY INVOLVES- WALKING ALL
AROUND THE FACILITY USING ALL OF
THE ON SITE- INFORMATION
AVAILABLE- IN YOU KNOW WITH THE
BIG. CHECKLIST AND ALL THE REST
WE ALSO TALK TO THE PEOPLE WHO
TALK WITH PEOPLE WHO ARE HOUSED
IN THE LOCAL FACILITY AND PEOPLE
WHO. WORK THERE- THE IMPORTANT
PART OF THAT IS PROCESS IS DO.
PATTERNS OF COMPLIANCE OR NON
COMPLIANCE- TURNING BACK TO THE
GOAL OF THE ENHANCED INSPECTION
PROCESS WHICH I MIGHT REFER TO
AS THE P. I. P. THE GOAL OF THAT
IS TO MORE ACTIVELY ENGAGE WITH-
THE COUNTIES WITH OUR BOARD. AND
TO PROVIDE INCREASED
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
TO ALL WHO ARE INTERESTED IN OUR
INSPECTIONS- I'M FOCUSING MOSTLY
ON ADULT DISABILITIES TODAY AS
NOTED. IN THE AGENDA FOR TODAY
THE BOARD DOES HAVE SOME
ADDITIONAL STATUTORY AUTHORITY
WITH RESPECT TO JUVENILE HALLS
AND WE CAN TAKE QUESTIONS ON
THAT LATER BUT FOR NOW I'M
FOCUSING ON OUR ADULT JAIL
INSPECTIONS. AS IS DESCRIBED IN
THE AGENDA OF THE BST SEEN AS A
STATE ENTITY THAT WAS DESIGNED
TO PROVIDE OVERSIGHT AND
ESTABLISHED REGULATIONS FOR JAIL
OPERATIONS AND THEN TO INSPECT
TO THOSE STANDARDS. AND I CAN
ABSOLUTELY SAY THAT I BELIEVE WE
CARRY OUT THOSE RESPONSIBILITIES
VERY WELL. IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
TO KEEP IN MIND THAT THE STATE
DOES NOT RUN A LOCAL JAILS CDCR
IS FULLY RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
OPERATION OF STATE PRISONS AND
THEY HAVE SOME. ADDITIONAL
AUTHORITY AND ABILITY TO
DISSECT- RULES AND SUCH WITH
RESPECT TO STATE PRISONS BUT THE
COUNTY. FACILITIES ARE THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF COUNTY
GOVERNMENT TO REALLY IMPORTANT
DISTINCTION- THE BSE SEEN AS AN
INSPECTION AND COMPLIANCE ENTITY
WE DON'T HAVE INVESTIGATIVE OR
ENFORCEMENT AUTHORITY WE DON'T
HAVE SUBPOENA POWER WE CAN'T
FILE CRIMINAL CHARGES WE CAN
ISSUE FINES. WE CAN'T GO TO
COURT TO SUE FOR COMPLIANCE AND
IN ADDITION AS THIS COMMITTEE IS
AWARE THERE ARE ATTORNEY GENERAL
OPINIONS STATING THAT. OUR
REGULATIONS ARE NOT MANDATORY.
BUT THE LESS IN CARRYING OUT OUR
RISK TO. CONSIST WITH THE
STATUTES AND THE AUTHORITY THAT
WE HAVE I THINK WE ARE
ABSOLUTELY MEETING THAT MARK.
AND I WOULD ALSO NOTE THAT THERE
ARE VERY MEANINGFUL INCENTIVES
FOR COUNTIES TO COMPLY WITH THE
STANDARDS AND I'M SURE OTHER
PANELISTS WILL ADDRESS SOME OF
THESE TOPICS. THERE ARE
CONSEQUENCES WHEN FACILITIES DO
NOT ABIDE BY THE REGULATIONS AND
THOSE INCLUDE. CIVIL LIABILITY
POTENTIAL LOSS OF EMPLOYMENT AND
POTENTIAL CRIMINAL LIABILITY-
AND IN THE LAST TWO YEARS IN
SPITE OF THE PANDEMIC WE HAVE
SIGNIFICANTLY ENHANCED THE
PUBLIC FACING ASPECTS OF OUR
INSPECTIONS- ALLISON GANTER OUR
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OVER INSPECTIONS
NOW WE'RE PORTS AT EACH PUBLIC
BOARD MEETING. ON THE STATUS OF
INSPECTIONS AND WHEN THERE IS A
CASE THAT ACCOUNTABILITY HAS NOT
ADDRESSED OUTSTANDING ITEMS OF
NON COMPLIANCE. FOLLOWING A
PRESCRIBED FOR CORRECTIVE ACTION
WE REQUEST TO SHARE HER
PROBATION GENES TO ATTEND THE
NEXT SCHEDULED BOARD MEETING TO
LET US KNOW WHAT THOSE ISSUES
ARE- AND SO THERE'S MUCH MORE
PUBLIC ACCOUNTABILITY THAT'S
TAKING PLACE. AT OUR APRIL BOARD
MEETING NEXT MONTH WE WILL BE
HEARING FROM ONE OF THE SHARES
IN BASED ON AN INVITATION LIKE
THAT. IN SUMMARY THE PURPOSE OF
THE JAIL INSPECTIONS TO
DETERMINE IF THE FACILITY IS IN
COMPLIANCE. WITH TITLE
DEREGULATION'S- ON THE ON.
ENTITLED FOUR PHYSICAL PLANT. IN
PROCESS AS I MENTIONED EARLIER
IS MULTI LAYERED IT INVOLVES
EXTENSIVE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
OUTSIDE OF THE ONSITE
INSPECTINS AND OUR INSPECTION
TEAM SPENDS TIME ENSURING THAT
CORRECTIVE ACTION IS HAPPENING
WHEN IT'S NEEDED. WITHIN THE
STATUTORY AUTHORITY THAT WE HAVE
WE HAVE DEVELOPED A RESPONSIVE
AND MEANINGFUL PROGRAM FOR THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA. AND I'M
AWARE THAT THE SUBCOMMITTEE WILL
ALSO BE DISCUSSING THE RECENT
AUDIT CONCERNING A- HIGHER THAN
AVERAGE RATE OF DEATHS IN
CUSTODY IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY.
THAT CAUGHT IT RAISES ISSUES OF
UTMOST CONCERN AND THE BOARD
WHILE WE TAKE ISSUE WITH SOME OF
THE AUDIT FINDINGS WE WILL BE
DISCUSSING FURTHER AT THE
RECOMMENDATIONS PERTAIN TO THE
BST C. N. OUTSIDE AND I WILL BE
HAPPY TO. ANY QUESTIONS THAT YOU
MAY HAVE. OKAY. THANK YOU MISS
HOWARD- WE WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
THE L. A. O. WHO WILL BE
PRESENTING. AFTERNOON MY INSURER
AND MEMBERS THIS IS CAITLIN
O'NEILL AT THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE WELCOME MISSILE
MAIL. THANK YOU. I'VE BEEN ASKED
TO PROVIDE A BRIEF OVERVIEW OF
AGE FORTY THAT WE PUBLISHED LAST
FEBRUARY ON BBC C. STANDARDS AND
INSPECTIONS PROGRAM. AND I'LL BE
SPEAKING FROM A HANDOUT- CALL
THE REVIEW OF STATE STANDARDS
AND INSPECTIONS FOR LOCAL
DETENTION FACILITIES WHICH ALONG
WITH OUR REPORT IS AVAILABLE ON
OUR WEBSITE AT LA O. DOT CA DOT
GOV- UNDER PUBLICATIONS TAB.
EIGHTY ONE. SOME BRIEF
BACKGROUND ON THE STC WHICH I
WON'T GO INTO IN THE INTEREST OF
TIME THOUGH IT IS HERE FOR YOUR
REFERENCE. NEEDS TO PROVIDE AN
OVERVIEW OF THE LOCAL DETENTION
FACILITY STANDARDS INSPECTION
PROGRAM WHICH IS ONE OF THE
SEC'S FOUR MAIN RESPONSIBILITIES
AND MISS HOWARD OKAY RT GAVE AN
OVERVIEW OF THIS BUT JUST AT A
VERY HIGH LEVEL JUST TO.
REITERATE THE KEY POINTS- STATUE
REQUIRES THE SEC PERFORM THREE
ACTIVITIES WHICH ARE TO MAINTAIN
OUR THREE MAIN IT MIGHT MEAN
ACTIVITIES WITH RESPECT TO THIS
PROGRAM WHICH ARE TO MAINTAIN.
THE MINIMUM STANDARDS FOR
FACILITY CONSTRUCTION AND
OPERATION I INSPECT FACILITIES
ON A REGULAR BASIS RELATIVE TO
THOSE STANDARDS- AND REPORT ON
COMPLIANCE WITH STANDARDS. AND
WE NOTE THAT. THE FCC DOES NOT
HAVE STATUTORY AUTHORITY TO-
DIRECTLY ENFORCE THE STANDARDS.
MOVING ON TO PAGE THREE WE ARE
DESCRIBED BRIEFLY THE
MODIFICATIONS AND THE SEC HAS
BEEN MAKING IN RESPONSE TO THE
GOVERNOR'S DIRECTIVE FROM THAT
EARLY TWENTY TWENTY. AND I ALSO
WON'T GO INTO MUCH DETAIL ON
THESE GIVEN THAT- MISS HOWARD
ALSO DESCRIBES SOME OF THESE
CHANGES BUT- GENERALLY WE THINK
THAT THERE ARE A STEP IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION BUT PROBABLY
DON'T GO FAR ENOUGH. ANNA REED
REASONING FOR THAT- CONCLUSION
SHOULDBECOME CLEAR IN MY
DISCUSSION OF OUR ASSESSMENT
WHICH ALL RIGHT- COVER PAGE FIVE
I'M IN REALLY IT'S VERY PRETTY
SIMPLE ASSESSMENT AT ITS HEART
WITH ME- AND THAT IS THAT WHEN
WE LOOK AT ANY PROGRAM WE ASK
WHAT ARE THE GOALS OF THE
PROGRAM AND IS IT MEETING THOSE
GOALS. AND WE FOUND IN THIS CASE
THAT THE PROGRAM DOES NOT HAVE A
CLEAR STATUTORY MISSION OR
GOALS- AND THIS LEAVES
SIGNIFICANT DISCRETION TO THE
ADMINISTRATION IN DEFINING. THE
MISSION AND GOALS OF THE
PROGRAM. THERE IS SOME CONCERN.
THAT THE INFORMAL MISSION
CURRENTLY OF THE PROGRAM IS
ESSENTIALLY TO PROMOTE LEGAL
HUMANE AND SAFE CONDITIONS
INSIDE LOCAL DETENTION
FACILITIES NOTHING. WOULD
PREVENT THE ADMINISTRATION FROM
OPERATING UNDER DIFFERENT
INFORMAL MISSION IN THE FUTURE.
IN ADDITION THE LACK OF CLEARLY
DEFINED GOALS. LEAVES
SIGNIFICANT DISCRETION FOR SEC
TO DETERMINE HOW WHATEVER AN
INFORMAL MISSION IT ADOPTS IS
ACHIEVED SO TO THE EXTENT THAT
B. B. C. C. FOR EXAMPLE DECIDED
THAT- IT WANTED TO FOCUS ON
PROMOTING TRANSPARENCY AROUND
CONDITIONS INSIDE DETENTION
FACILITIES. THEN ONE WOULD
EXPECT THE REPORTING REQUIREMENT
TO BE FULFILLED BY- REPORTS THAT
ARE VERY ACCESSIBLE TO LAY
PERSON AUDIENCES IN CONTRAST TO
THE EXTENT THE STC CHOSE TO
FOCUS INSTEAD MORE NARROWLY ON-
PROVIDING A SERVICE TO LOCAL
DETENTION FACILITY
ADMINISTRATORS- IT WHAT ONE
WOULD EXPECT THE REPORT
REASONABLY EXPECT THE REPORTS TO
CONTAIN JARGON AND- BE WRITTEN
FOR MORE FOR A FACILITY
ADMINISTRATOR. AUDIENCE AND THEN
FINALLY THAT LACK OF A CLEAR
MISSION AND GOALS UNDERMINES
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT OF THE
PROGRAM. AND THAT'S BECAUSE
IT'S- IT'S SIMPLY WITHOUT CLEAR
GOALS IS DIFFICULT TO ASSESS
WHETHER THE PROGRAM FOR FILLS AN
IMPORTANT STATE FUNCTIONS THAT
IS CONSISTENT WITH LEGISLATIVE
PRIORITIES- WHETHER IT'S
APPROPRIATELY STRUCTURED A
RESOURCE. AND WHETHER IT IS
OPERATING EFFECTIVELY AND
ACHIEVING ITS GOALS. WHICH
MOVING ON TO PAGE FIVE OF THE
REST OF MY COMMENTS AND HAND OUT
PERTAINING TO OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS IN LIGHT OF THIS
ASSESSMENT AND A HIGH LEVEL WE
HAVE THREE MAIN RECOMMENDATIONS
WHICH ARE TO ONE SIDE A CLEAR
MISSION AND GOALS IN STATUTE FOR
THE PROGRAM. TO ALIGN THE BOARD
MEMBERSHIP WEST THAT MISSION AND
GOALS AND THREE TO REQUIRE BSE
SEAT TO SUBMIT A REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE ON HOW IT WILL ALIGN
THE PROGRAM WITH THE MISSION AND
GOALS. YOU'RE GOING INTO A
LITTLE BIT MORE DETAIL ON ON
THOSE RECOMMENDATIONS. OUR FIRST
RECOMMENDATION AS I MENTIONED IS
TO ESTABLISH A CLEAR PROGRAM
MISSION AND GOALS AND OF COURSE
THE LEGISLATURE COULD CHOOSE ANY
MISSION AND GOALS THAT IT DEEMS
APPROPRIATE BUT WE DO RECOMMEND
SOME SPECIFIC MISSION AND GOALS-
AND ON A MISSION WE RECOMMEND IS
TO PROMOTE LEGAL HUMANE AND SAFE
CONDITIONS INSIDE LOCAL
DETENTION FACILITIES. AND TO
FURTHER THAT MISSION WE
RECOMMEND FOR SPECIFIC GOALS.
WHICH ARE TO ONE MAINTAIN
STANDARDS THAT HELP LOCAL
LEADERS DETERMINE AND MEET LEGAL
REQUIREMENTS WHICH CAN BE
COMPLEX AND DIFFICULT TO
TRANSLATE- INTO PRACTICE TO
FACILITATE TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THE PUBLIC-
AND OTHER STAKEHOLDERS. THROUGH
STANDARDS AND INSPECTIONS. THREE
TO PROMOTE EQUITABLE PROVISION
OF LEGAL HUMANIST- AND SAFE
CONDITIONS. AND FOR TO PROVIDE
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND
STATEWIDE LEADERSHIP TO
FACILITATE SYSTEMIC IMPROVEMENT
. AND AS I NOTED OUR SECOND
RECOMMENDATION- WHEN IT IS TO
ALIGN THE BOARD MEMBERSHIP WITH
THE MISSION WHATEVER MISSION AND
GOALS OF THE LEGISLATURE SELECTS
AND BASED ON OUR RECOMMENDED
MISSION AND GOALS WE THINK THAT-
IT WOULD MAKE SENSE TO BALANCE
THE BOARD MEMBERSHIP IN ORDER TO
FACILITATE MORE OF AN OVERSIGHT
ROLE. AND THAT'S BECAUSE THE
BOARD CURRENTLY- HAS NO MEMBERS
WITH PROFESSIONAL EXPERTISE IN
EXTERNAL OVERSIGHT OF DETENTION
FACILITIES AS OF JANUARY TWENTY
TWENTY TWO BEFORE RECENT VACANCY
OPENED UP ON THE BOARD- SEVEN OF
THE THIRTEEN B. SEC BOARD
MEMBERS WERE ADMINISTRATORS OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES FOR
WHICH- OPERATED FACILITIES THAT.
WERE INSPECTED BY THE PROGRAM.
SO THE BOARD HAS NO SHORTAGE OF
IMPORTANT EXPERTISE ON OPERATION
OF LOCAL DETENTION FACILITIES
BUT IT LACKS EXPERTISE. ON
EXTERNAL OVERSIGHT OF SUCH
FACILITIES WHICH WE SEE AS A
DIFFERENT FORM OF EXPERTISE THAT
IS IMPORTANT- GIVEN THE THIS IS
A KEY ELEMENT OF THE BOOK AT THE
BOARD'S MAIN RESPONSIBILITIES.
AND THEN WE ALSO RECOMMEND- THAT
THE LEGISLATURE INCREASING
NUMBER MEMBERS APPOINTED BY THE
LEGISLATURE CURRENTLY ONLY
CURRENTLY TEN OUT OF THIRTEEN
BOARD MEMBERS ARE APPOINTED BY
THE GOVERNOR. WE THINK HAVING-
MORE BOARD MEMBERS APPOINTED BY
THE LEGISLATURE COULD- ENHANCE
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT OF THE OF
THE BOARD OVERALL AND THE
PROGRAM IN PARTICULAR. AND
MOVING ON PAGE SEVEN. HERE WE
DID TELL THE- THIRD
RECOMMENDATION WHICH IS TO
REQUIRE A PLAN TO- REQUIRED THE
SEC TO SUBMIT A PLAN TO THE
LEGISLATURE ON HOW IT WOULD
ALIGN THE PROGRAM WITH ITS WITH
THE NEW MISSION AND GOALS. AND
WE THINK THAT HAVING THIS PLAN
WOULD ENABLE THE LEGISLATURE TO
DETERMINE WHETHER ANY STATUTORY
CHANGES ARE NEEDED- OR WHETHER
THE SEC NEEDS ANY ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES TO IMPLEMENT THE PLAN
IT WOULD ALSO FACILITATE FUTURE
EVALUATION OF PROGRAM
EFFECTIVENESS. AND TO GUIDE THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THIS PLAN WE
RECOMMEND REQUIRING THAT THE
PLAN DESCRIBED HOW THE SEC WOULD
ACHIEVE FIVE KEY OUTCOMES. WHICH
ARE ONE THAT THE PLAN SHOULD
OUTLINE HOW THE STANDARDS WILL
BE REVISED TO BE MORE SUSPICIOUS
SPECIFIC SUCH THAT THEY
EFFECTIVELY COMMUNICATE WHAT
LEGAL HUMANE AND SAFE CONDITIONS
ARE. AND ENSURE THAT THE
STANDARDS ARE EQUITABLY ADDRESS
THE SPECIALIZED NEEDS OF ALL
INMATES AND IT CAN YOU- TO THE
PLAN SHOULD INCLUDE
CONSIDERATION OF KEY INFORMATION
SUCH AS REPORTED STANDARDS
VIOLATIONS. BY THIRD PARTIES
ESSENTIALLY- BOARD ESSENTIALLY
REPORTS THAT ARE NOT- JUST
DISCOVERED BY DSCC INSPECTORS
BUT YOU KNOW COULD BE REPORTED
BY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC- AND
NOT BE A CC COULD USE THIS FOR
EXAMPLE AS A WAY TO ADD MORE
STRATEGICALLY TARGET INSPECTIONS
- AND THEN THREE THE PLAN SHOULD
INDICATE HOW THE SEC WILL
DEVELOP CLEAR AND TRANSPARENT
BENCHMARKS FOR INSPECTIONS- IS
SUCH AS- GUIDANCE. FOR
INTERPRETING SUBJECTIVITY IN THE
STANDARDS AND QUALITY ASSURANCE
PROCESS TO INSURANCE SECTORS
MEET THESE BENCHMARKS. FOUR THE
PLAN SHOULD OUTLINE HOW THE SEC
WILL IMPROVE THE QUALITY OF ITS
REPORTING ON THE RESULTS OF
INSPECTIONS- AND I WOULD NOT BE
SEC HAS MADE SOME SOME CHANGES
IN THIS RESPECT WHICH HAVE BEEN
HELPFUL BUT I THINK WE THINK
THAT DATE THAT- THE FTC COULD GO
FURTHER SUCH AS BY. ISSUING
SPECIAL REPORTS TO HIGHLIGHT
CERTAIN- SEVERE CONCERNS ARE
TIME SENSITIVE ISSUES- AND
NUMBER FIVE- THE PLAN SHOULD
GIVE CONSIDERATION TO PROVIDING
LONGER TERM MORE COMPLEX
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO
FACILITIES TO HELP ADDRESS- MORE
INTRACTABLE ISSUES THAT CAN TAKE
LONGER THAN SIX THE CURRENT
SIXTY DAY. COMPLIANCE PERIOD TO
ADDRESS AS WELL AS HOW THE FCC
CAN HELP- HELP HIGHLIGHT AND
PROMOTE PROMISING PRACTICES TO
FACILITATE. CONTINUOUS SYSTEMIC
IMPROVEMENT IN DETENTION
FACILITY CONDITIONS ACROSS THE
STATE. AND THAT BRINGS ME TO THE
END OF MY PREPARED COMMENTS AND
I'M HAPPY TO TAKE QUESTIONS AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS O'NEILL OUR NEXT
WE'RE GOING TO HEAR FROM THE
CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITOR- WHO
WHO WILL BE PRESENTING FOR THE
CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITOR. OKAY
YES NOW DO YOU HI GOOD AFTERNOON
I AM CHAIR AND MEMBER OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS NICHOLA
EACH US WITH THE STATE AUDITOR'S
OFFICE AND I WAS THE PROJECT
MANAGER OF OUR RECENT REPORT ON
LCD- COUNTY JAILS. YOUR HONOR
FOCUSED ON THESE DEATHS THAT
OCCURRED AT A SAN DIEGO JAILS
AND WE FOCUS ON THREE MAIN
AREAS- WE FOCUSED ON THE CARE
THAT'S PROVIDED. THE SAFETY THAT
THAT THAT THEY PERFORM AND ALSO
HOW THE RESPONSE TO THESE DEATHS
WITHOUT SIGNIFICANT ISSUES
ACROSS ALL OF THESE AREAS WE
HAVE SEVERAL RECOMMENDATIONS ON
HOW. TO ADDRESS THOSE PROBLEMS-
ALSO TOOK A STEP. AND LOOK AT
THE STATE AS A WHOLE AND WE
NOTED THAT THE NUMBER OF IN
CUSTODY DEATHS OVER THE PAST
FIFTEEN YEARS HAVE BEEN
INCREASING. AND WE LOOK FOR WE
LOOK AT WAYS THAT PROTECTION THE
STATE COULD REDUCE THE NUMBER OF
DEATHS. AND WE LOOKED AT STATE
STANDARDS AND TRY TO IDENTIFY
SOME GAPS. AND SO WE LOOKED AT
THE BORDER CITY COMMUNITY
CORRECTIONS THE BSE. AND WE
REVIEW THE REGULATIONS AND TRY
TO SEE WHAT OTHER CHANGES THAT
COULD THEY COULD MAKE THAT WHEN
THE FACTS ARE THAT WHERE MOST OF
THE INDIVIDUALS ARE HOUSE IN
CALIFORNIA COURTS FOR YOU
BECAUSE OUR HOUSE CALIFORNIA. TO
MAKE IMPROVEMENTS TO PREVENT
THIS FROM OCCURRING AND WE FOCUS
ON THREE MAIN AREAS BASED ON OUR
FINDINGS ON THE AUDIT. INTAKE
HOW ARE THE SCREENING-
INDIVIDUALS WHEN THE INTERFACE
SIMILARLY TO IDENTIFY MENTAL
HEALTH NEEDS SO THAT THEY CAN
MAKE SURE THAT THEY GET THE CARE
THAT THEY NEED. THE SECOND PART
WOULD BE SAFETY. HOW ARE THE
CHECKING ON THE SAFETY OF
INDIVIDUALS NOW YOU DO THE
HOURLY ROUNDS THAT- DEPUTIES
PERFORMED TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
INDIVIDUAL IS ALIVE AND WELL.
AND LASTLY TRAINING. ARE THE
TRAINING REQUIREMENTS ARE FOR
THE STATE OF OUR STATE
CORRECTIONS OFFICERS AT LOCAL
DETENTION FACILITIES.
APPROPRIATE SO THAT THEY HAVE
THE TOOLS THAT THEY NEED. IN
ORDER FOR THEM TO BE ABLE TO
RESPOND TO MEDICAL EMERGENCIES
AND OTHER CRISES THAT EIGHT IN
THERE BY PREVENTING THESE DEATHS
. NOW IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE DOT
BSE STANDARDS ARE MINIMUM
STANDARDS. AT EITHER DESIGNED SO
THAT ALL FACILITIES I WOULD BE
ABLE TO MEET THEM SO WHETHER
YOU'RE A LARGE FACILITY OR SMALL
ONE. THAT'S WHEN WE PERFORMED
OUR ARTISTS AND WE LOOKED AT
MULTIPLE SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENTS
IT WAS NOT SURPRISING THAT THERE
WAS A MARKED A LOT OF
INCONSISTENCY- IN THEIR POLICIES
. SO WE DEVELOP SOME
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WE BELIEVE
THAT STANDARDS NEED TO BE
ELEVATED AT LEAST FOR THE LARGER
FACILITIES IN ORDERSO THAT
THERE'S A STANDARD OF CARE
PROVIDED. THAT THAT PROTECTS.
THE INSIGNIFICANT JORDY OF THE
INCARCERATED POPULATION
CALIFORNIA. SO FOR THE FIRST
PART INTAKE- STATE REGULATIONS
DO NOT REQUIRE A MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONAL TO SCREEN
INDIVIDUALS AT INTAKE. AND THUS
A LOT OF MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS MAY
GO UNDETECTED AND THE MAY I GET
THE CARE THEY NEED WHEN THEY GET
INTO THE FACILITY. I'M IN SAN
DIEGO WE FOUND THAT HAPPENING
MULTIPLE TIMES WE BELIEVE. AND
WE'RE RECOMMENDING DOCKS- THE
REGULATIONS BE UPDATED TO
REQUIRE FOR LARGER FACILITIES.
THAT A MENTAL HEALTH CLINICIAN
EVALUATES INDIVIDUALS AT INTAKE
SO THAT THEY COULD MOST
PROPERLY- I IDENTIFY THESE MEN
HEALTH NEEDS AND TO THIS DAY
THEY RECEIVE ON THAT CARE THAT
THEY NEED. THE SECOND PART
RELATES TO SAFETY CHECKS. NOW
AND IT DOES STATE REGULATIONS AT
THE TIME OF OUR AUDITS REQUIRED
THAT THE SAFETY CHECKS WHEN
YOU'RE PERFORMING THESE ARE THE
ROUNDS. ONLY ARE PERFORMED USING
DIRECT VISUAL OBSERVATION BUT
THEY DON'T REALLY EXPANSIONIST
RUN THE NOW. AND AS A RESULT WE
SAW THE WIDE VARIATION BETWEEN
HOW DIFFERENT APARTMENTS ARE A
CHEF'S APARTMENTS ARE CHECKING
ON THE STATUS OF INDIVIDUALS- IN
SAN DIEGO IN PARTICULAR WHAT WE
FOUND IS WE LOOK AT HOURS OF
VIDEO. AND WE FOUND THAT
OFFICERS WOULD WALK DOWN THE
HALL STOCKLEY TIME'S WITHOUT
BREAKING STRIDE BARELY GLANCING
MISSILE ONLY TO FIND OUT THAT
INDIVIDUAL HAS BEEN DEAD FOR
HOURS AND NO ONE. NO ONE NOTICED
. SO WE'RE REQUIRING THAT A
WRITTEN RECOMMENDING THAT THERE
BE A CC UPDATES REGULATIONS. SO
THAT DAY IS SPECIFICALLY
REQUIRES THAT YOU'RE CHECKING TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE INDIVIDUAL IS
ALIVE. AND IN FACT THIS IS
ACTUALLY CONSISTENT WITH- THE
WAY C. C. R. POLICIES ON SAFETY
CHECKS AND THEY ACTUALLY REQUIRE
YOU CHECK MAKE SURE THAT
INDIVIDUALS LIVE. AND LASTLY
TRAINING. WE LOOK AT COMPARABLE
PROFESSIONS- AGAINST THAT COULD
LOCAL CORRECTION OFFICERS AND WE
LOOKED AT PROBATION OFFICERS AND
YOU LOOK AT JUVENILE DETENTION
OFFICERS AND WE LOOK AT THEIR
TRAINING REQUIREMENTS AND WE
FOUND OUT THAT THE CAR WAS FOR
COMMISSIONED OFFICERS AND
JUVENILE DETENTION OFFICERS WERE
HIGHER THAN THEY ARE FOR LOCAL.
DETENTION OFFICERS. GIVEN THE
PROBLEMS THAT WE SAW IN THE
COURSE OF SAN DIEGO ON IT IN A
REVIEW OF ALL THE SHARES
FACILITIES. RELATED TO HARDLY
MISSED RESPONDING TO MEDICAL
EMERGENCIES HOW ARE YOU
PERFORMING SAFETY CHECKS IT ONLY
MAKES SENSE. THAT THAT DESTROYED
ENVIRONMENTS ARE INCREASED TO
ALIGN WITH SIMILAR PROFESSIONS.
AND ESPECIALLY SINCE THE NUMBER
OF DEATHS HAVE BEEN INCREASING
OVER TIME AT THESE FACILITIES.
AND WE ALSO RECOMMEND THAT A
PORTION OF THESE DESTROYING MEAN
SHOULD BE RELATED TO MENTAL
HEALTH. AND GOING FORWARD.
BECAUSE BCC'S REGULATIONS- DO
TOUCH ON NUMEROUS HEALTH AND
SAFETY MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES IT
IT ALL ENDS GIVEN THE ISSUES
THAT WE FOUND AT SAN DIEGO AND
AS PART OF OUR AUDIT IT ONLY
MAKES SENSE FOR THEM TO ADD TO
THEIR BOARD A MEDICAL AND MENTAL
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS WHETHER
DEVELOPING THESE REGULATIONS THE
R. CORPORATION BEST PRACTICES.
TO ENSURE SO THAT- SO- SHIFT
PARMA'S PROCESS STATE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IT WAS VERY
HELPFUL- WE ARE MUCH MORE. WE'RE
GONNA- HERE NOW FROM DON SPECTER
WITH THE PRISON LAW OFFICE. MR
SPECTER. S. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIRMAN AND I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE AND
ADDRESS YOUR TODAY- THE PRISON
LAW OFFICES- LEAVE PUBLIC
INTEREST LAW FIRM AND WE'RE
DEDICATED TO IMPROVING
CONDITIONS IN CALIFORNIA'S
CORRECTIONAL FACILITIES. OUR
ULTIMATE GOAL IS TO ENSURE THAT
THIS. PEOPLE IN THOSE FACILITIES
ARE SAFE AND THAT THE CONDITIONS
MEET CONSTITUTIONAL STANDARDS.
AND TO DO THAT WORK- WE ARE IN
THE PRISONS WELL PRIOR TO COVE
AND- WE'RE IN THE PRISONS OR
JAILS VIRTUALLY EVERY WEEK- MOST
MILD. MUCH OF OUR WORK INVOLVES
INSPECTING THE CONDITIONS IN
CORRECTIONAL FACILITIES
MONITORING COMPLIANCE WITH
VARIOUS COURT DECREES- AND- ALSO
INTERNAL REGULATIONS OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS. PART
OF OUR WORK HAS BEEN- TO
INVESTIGATE CONDITIONS IN COUNTY
JAILS. AND AS THE AGENDA SETS
FORTH- ELEVEN COUNTIES HAVE BEEN
SUED BY US OR OTHER FIRMS
SEEKING STATEWIDE INJUNCTIVE
RELIEF IN CLASS ACTIONS IN
FEDERAL COURT. BECAUSE THE
CONDITIONS IN THE JAILS ARE- WAY
BEYOND- CONSTITUTIONAL- MINIMUM
- I THINK THAT FACT ALONE IS
PROOF THAT THE DSCC IS NOT
EFFECTIVELY ACCOMPLISHING WHAT I
BELIEVE IT SHOULD IT'S CALL
SHOULD BE. WHICH IS TO PROVIDE
OVERSIGHT AND TO ENSURE THAT-
THE CONDITIONS IN THE COUNTY
JAILS TO MEET OUR STANDARDS SET
FORTH WHAT MAKES STANDARDS THAT
ARE CONSISTENT WITH THE
CONSTITUTION AND OTHER LAWS-
BASED ON THIS EXPERIENCE AND
OTHERS EXPERIENCE I BELIEVE
THAT- MOST OF THE COUNTY JAILS.
IN CALIFORNIA PROBABLY ARE
UNCONSTITUTIONAL ONE
CONSTITUTIONAL CONDITIONS IN AT
LEAST SOME RESPECTS EVERY SINGLE
ONE THAT WE'VE INSPECTED WE
FOUND SERIOUS PROBLEMS AND I
DOUBT THAT THAT'S- HEY ABNORMAL
SITUATION. SO- IN TERMS OF THAT
WHAT THE BSE SEES ROLE IS AND
WHAT IT HAS DONE IN THE PAST I
CAN SAY- AMPLIFY WHAT- THE OTHER
PANELISTS HAVE HINTED AT BEFORE
WHICH IS THAT THE REGULATIONS
DRAFTED BY THE B. SEC- ARE NOT
VERY HELPFUL- THEY ARE. THE
REGULATIONS AND OFTEN REQUIRE
JUST A WRITTEN POLICY- THEY NEED
TO BE INSTEAD THEY NEED TO BE
VERY SPECIFIC AND SET FORTH
MINIMUM REQUIREMENTS WHICH THEY
DO NOT DO FOR EXAMPLE I'LL GIVE
YOU TWO EXAMPLES- SECTION ONE OH
FIVE THREE REQUIRES A POLICY FOR
ADMINISTRATIVE SEGREGATION WHICH
IS A EUPHEMISM FOR SOLITARY
CONFINEMENT-THAT REGULAR.
DOESN'T SPECIFY THE
CIRCUMSTANCES ANSWERS WHICH CAN
RESULT IN PLACE ANOTHER PERSON
IN SOLITARY CONFINEMENT HOW LONG
HERE SHE- SHOULD BE IN THAT
SITUATION IT DOESN'T PROVIDE FOR
THE EXCLUSION- PEOPLE WITH
MENTAL ILLNESS FROM BEING HOUSED
IN SOLITARY CONFINEMENT AS IS
REQUIRED BY THE CONSTITUTION.
AND DOESN'T REQUIRE- AND DOESN'T
REQUIRE. WRITTEN REGULATIONS
ABOUT HOW SOMEBODY CAN GET OUT
OF SOLITARY CONFINEMENT. ANOTHER
EXAMPLE IS SECTION TWELVE ELEVEN
WHICH MERELY STATES THAT THERE
SHALL BE WRITTEN POLICIES AND
PROCEDURES WHICH PROVIDE FOR THE
DAILY SICK CALL CONDUCTED FOR
ALL INMATES WERE PROVISION MADE
THAT ANY INMATE REQUESTING
MEDICAL AND MENTAL HEALTH
ATTENTION BE GIVEN SIX TENSION.
HERE AGAIN THERE ARE NO DETAILS-
THERE IS NOTHING ABOUT WHO SHE
CONDUCTS THE CALL HOUSE THE
CALLS REQUEST SHOULD BE
PROCESSED. THERE'S NO
REQUIREMENTS FOR THE CLINICIAN
TO SPEAK WITH THE PATIENT MUCH
LESS A TIME FRAME IN WHICH A
REFERRAL SHOULD BE MADE
DEPENDING ON THE SEVERITY OF THE
COMPLAINT ALL OF THESE THINGS.
ARE REQUIRED I BELIEVE BY THE
CONSTITUTION. AND THE
REGULATIONS DON'T EVEN COME
CLOSE TO PROVIDING THAT KIND OF
LEVEL OF SPECIFICITY. SECONDLY
THE DSCC PROCESS HASN'T WORKED
VERY WELL BECAUSE THE JAILS NEED
TO HAVE ADEQUATE AND RELIABLE
DATA TO SHOW. AS FAR AS I KNOW
THERE IS NO SUCH REQUIREMENT.
THIRD- THE INSTRUCTIONS AS I
UNDERSTAND THEM I'M NEVER SEEN
ONE BUT AS I UNDERSTAND IT THEY
LOOK AT WRITTEN POLICIES AND I
TAKE CARE OF THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR'S WORD FOR IT THAT
THEY- WALK AROUND THE
INSTITUTION AND- TALK TO PEOPLE
BUT I. DOUBT THAT THEY HAVE DONE
THAT IN SUFFICIENT DETAIL IN
ORDER TO- DETERMINE ALL THE
ISSUES THAT ARE PRESENT IN THE
JAIL AND TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
CORRECT THEM. TO DO THAT THE
INSPECTORS HAVE TO REVIEW LOTS
OF RECORDS INTERVIEW STAFFS
MAYBE THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
INCARCERATED IN THE JAILS. AND
DETERMINE WHETHER THE POLICIES.
YOU ARE ACTUALLY. BEING FOLLOWED
AND PROVIDE DATA TO SUPPORT THAT
. PROBABLY OUR ONE OF THE MORE
IMPORTANT GOSH DEFICIENCIES IN
THEM THE SEC PROCESSES BEEN
ALLUDED TO BY THAT- PRIOR
PANELISTS AND THAT'S THE FACT
THAT THERE ARE REALLY NO DIRECT
CONSEQUENCES BESIDES SHOWING UP
AT A MEETING OF THE BOARD- FOR.
NON COMPLIANCE WITH THE
INADEQUATE REGULATIONS- THIS IS-
WITHOUT SOME CONSEQUENCES
IMPOSSIBLE TO HOLD THESE SHARES
IN THE COUNTY'S ACCOUNTABLE FOR
THE POOR CONDITIONS AND THAT
DOESN'T PROVIDE AN INCENTIVE FOR
THEM TO MAKE THE CHANGES THAT
ARE NECESSARY. WHICH I THINK HAS
RESULTED IN THE CONSTITUTIONAL
CONDITIONS THAT WE'VE DISCOVERED
ON MULTIPLE OCCASIONS. AND THE
OTHER- ISSUE ABOUT THE
INSPECTIONS IS AS I UNDERSTAND
THE INSPECTORS ARE OR- ARE NOT.
EXPERTS SUCH AS PHYSICIANS- WE
ROUTINELY AND IT SAID IT WOULD
BE IN MY VIEW- I'M NOT PRACTICE
NOT TO EMPLOY. EXPERTS IN
SUBJECT MATTER AREAS DURING THE
INSPECTIONS TO DETERMINE WHETHER
OR NOT- CERTAIN THINGS ARE
ACTUALLY TAKING PLACE FOR
EXAMPLE AND MEDICAL CARE TO
VALUATE THE MEDICAL CARE SYSTEM
YOU NEED TO HAVE. A PHYSICIAN.
FOR A NURSE AND OR A NURSE-
EVALUATE WHETHER THE PATIENTS
ARE GETTING APPROPRIATE CARE AND
I DON'T THINK THAT SIDE AS WELL
. FINALLY I WOULD SAY THAT IT'S
REALLY NOT AN EASY PROCESS TO
CHANGE THE POLICIES PROCEDURES
AND IN SOME CASES THE CULTURE
OF- CORRECTIONAL INSTITUTION IT
TAKES A LOT OF TIME CERTAINLY
SIXTY DAYS THIS. WAY IS VERY
INADEQUATE OUR- OUR CONSENT
DECREES LAST YEAR'S- NOT DAYS OR
OUR MINDS- IT TAKES CONSTANT
OVERSIGHT IT TAKES TIME IT TAKES
DEDICATION. A DEDICATED
ATTENTION TO PROBLEMS BY BOTH
THE INSPECTORS AND- THE
MANAGEMENT OF THE FACILITY IT
TAKES A WILLINGNESS TO CHANGE
AND- MOST IMPORTANTLY- IT TAKES
IT USUALLY TAKES MORE FINANCIAL
RESOURCES AND IN EVERY CASE THAT
WE'VE HAD AGAINST THE COUNTY
JAIL THAT'S BEEN THE CASE-
WITHOUT. WITHOUT OUR- ADVOCACY
AND LITIGATION- IS THERE'S EVERY
REASON FOR THE COUNTIES NOT TO
PROVIDE- THE MONEY IT TAKES
RISKS SAY FOR EXAMPLE HEALTH
CARE IN ORDER TO IN ORDER TO.
NEED APPROPRIATE- CLINICAL AND
CONSTITUTIONAL STANDARDS. SO I
BELIEVE THAT ARE ROLLED OUT OF
THE PRISON LAW OFFICE IN THE
STATE HAS BEEN TO PROVIDE- AND
SUMMERS IN SOME LIMITED RESPECTS
THE OVERSIGHT THAT THE BSE C.
SHOULD PROPERLY BE PERFORMING-
AND THAT SETTING APPROPRIATE
STANDARDS THAT ARE CONSISTENT
WITH THE CONSTITUTION AND OTHER
LAWS SUCH AS THE AMERICANS WITH
DISABILITY ACT. AND RIGOROUSLY
MONITORING COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE
STANDARDS- IT SEEMS TO ME HAT
THE STATE HAS A CHOICE IT CAN
IMPROVE THE B. SEC REGULATORY
PRACTICE. AND I WOULD AGREE
THAT- THE CHANGES THAT WERE MADE
LAST YEAR ARE A GOOD FIRST STEP
IN THAT DIRECTION. OR I CAN
MAINTAIN THE STATUS QUO- WHICH
WILL MEAN THAT MORE COUNTIES
WILL BE SUBJECT TO COSTLY AND
TIME CONSUMING LITIGATION IN THE
FUTURE SO. I VERY MUCH URGE. YOU
ALL TO. HE HAD SOME OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT ARE MADE
BEFORE SPECIALLY- MAKING SURE
THAT THE REPRESENTATION. AND- ON
THE BOARD- IS MORE BALANCED THAN
IT IS NOW WE'VE HAD. CETERA.
FIVE FIFTY YEARS AGO WE TRIED TO
GET SOME AGREEMENTS WITH SOME
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES ON SOME
OF THE MORE PRESSING ISSUES IN
THE JAILS- ONLY TO BE TOLD THAT
THEY WERE VERY HAPPY WITH THE-
THE SEC REGULATIONS AND- SO-
CORRECT. THOSE CONDITIONS DIDN'T
IMPROVE UNTIL WE- INSTITUTED
LEGAL ACTION AND ARE UNLESS THE-
REGULATORY. FRAMEWORK IS
STRENGTHENED- I DON'T THINK THEY
WILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER SPECTER-
GREATLY APPRECIATE ALL THE ALL
THE WORK THAT YOU'RE DOING AND
ALSO FOR BEING HERE. NEXT WE
WANT TO HEAR FROM A. D. LEWIS
WITH DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA. HELLO MISTER LEWIS.
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR
INVITING US MY NAME IS ETIENNE
I'M AN ATTORNEY AND A DISPLAY-
IT'S CALIFORNIA I WORK ON
CONDITIONS OF CONFINEMENT ISSUES
I'VE FOUND AT OUR TRANS ADVOCACY
PROJECT WHICH FOCUSES ON ISSUES
THAT TRANS NON BINARY AND
INTERSEX INDIVIDUALS WITH
DISABILITIES FACE MARXISM. PART
OF THIS WORK I ALSO WORKED IN
GOVERNMENT OVERSIGHT INCLUDING
AS A PERFORMANCE. THE LOCAL
LEVEL I'M INCLUDING OTHER LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES.
THOROUGHFARE ALONG GRAND HERE
SEE WHAT THE AUTHORITY TO ACCESS
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE FACILITIES TO
PROVIDE SERVICES AND TREATMENT
OF PEOPLE DISABILITY. R. C. HAS
USED ITS ACCESSORY TO MONITOR
AND INVESTIGATE JAILS ACROSS THE
STATE. WE HAVE INVESTIGATIONS
FOR CASES AND JAILS IN
SACRAMENTO IT'S HAMPER COUNTIES
AMONG OTHERS AND WE BRIEFLY I'M
SITTING AT WORK OTHER COUNTIES
INCLUDING SAN DIEGO AND PRESTO.
THIS WORK WE'VE SEEN FIRSTHAND
HOW JAILS CRIMINALLY AGAINST
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES. FOR
EXAMPLE GELS ARE TEAMING PLACE
INDIVIDUALS WITH DISABILITIES
RANGING FROM DIABETES DIABETES
TO SLEEP APNEA TO THOSE WHO USE
WHEELCHAIRS AND CANES AND
SEPARATION AND HIGHLY
RESTRICTIVE ENVIRONMENTS. WITH
LIMITED OR NO ACCESS TO
PROGRAMMING SOCIAL INTERACTION
EDUCATIONAL ACTIVITIES FOR
ADEQUATE MENTAL AND MEDICAL
CARE. WE'VE ALSO SEEN SHELL
SYSTEMS WITH THIS SO I'M
CONSTRUCTION AND PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES FROM ACCESSING SUCH
PROGRAMS MEDICAL CARE AN
INTEGRATED HOUSING CENTERS.
WE'VE ALSO SEEN JAILS OUT OF
PROVIDE EFFECTIVE COMMUNICATION
TO DEATH AND THE VISUALS AND TO
INDIVIDUALS WITH INTELLECTUAL OR
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES. OUR
WORK WE'VE WITNESSED HOW TO
SPELL HOW PEOPLE DISABILITIES
ESPECIALLY BLACK MY NEXT PEOPLE
ARE OVERREPRESENTED IN THE
CRIMINAL LEGAL SYSTEM. BUT WE'VE
ALSO SEEN HOW DETENTION
CONDITIONS ARE DISABLING AND
ABOUT THEMSELVES INCARCERATION
RESULTS AND MORE NEW MENTAL
HEALTH DIAGNOSES. LIKE PTSD
ANXIETY AND DEPRESSION CURSORY
SHOULD ALSO SERIOUSLY EXACERBATE
EXISTING MENTAL HEALTH
CONDITION. LIKE TRIGGER MANIC
EPISODES AND EXACERBATING.
PARANOID OR DELUSIONAL SOMETIMES
. WHILE OUR WORK LIKE KILO WORK
AS MANY CLICKS THESE COMMENTS
WERE PRACTICES. WE WERE THAT
THIS MIGHT SHIFT ARE NOT. YES
THE C. OVERSIGHT WILL BE A
MINIMAL UTILITY UNLESS AND UNTIL
IT CONSIDERS THE CONTEXT WHICH
INCARCERATION EXPRESSED IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. A
REMARKABLY LARGE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA JAILS ARE
RECEIVING OR ELIGIBLE TO RECEIVE
MENTAL HEALTH AND OTHER SERVICES
IN THE COMMUNITY. SERVICES AND
SITE JAIL SHOULD NOT EXIST ON A
SEPARATE PAYMENT FROM THE
CURRENT SERVICES BEING PROVIDED
IN THE COMMUNITY THAT'S WHAT YOU
ALL HAVE DONE FOR DECADES NOW.
AND THIS DIFFERENCE IS A MAJOR
REASON WHY WE SEE PEOPLE WITH
MENTAL HEALTH AND OTHER
DISABILITIES CYCLING IN AND OUT
OF INCARCERATION JAILS PRISONS
ETCETERA AS WELL AS OTHER FORMS
OF INSTITUTIONALIZATION
INCLUDING PSYCHIATRIC.
FACILITIES HOSPITALS. THE
SHERMANS RESPECT UNDERSTAND.
INSIDE OF A TEAM IN THE SEC
STANDARDS AS THEY CURRENTLY
EXIST. FALL SHORT OF LEGAL AND
CONSTITUTIONAL REQUIREMENTS FOR
JUST THE SUN'S CONSISTENTLY
DEVELOPING CASE LAW. THAT IS THE
SAME AS FOR JOE CONDITIONS AND
PRACTICES THAT WORK AND HELP THE
TEAM IN THE SEC GUIDANCE.
RANGING FROM OUT OF CELL TIME TO
PROGRAM ACCESS FOR PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES. TELL THE GUY TELL
SYSTEM TOWARDS THE GOAL AND
CONSTITUTIONAL MINIMUM
STANDARDS. AND NOT TELL YOUR
HURTS EVERYONE. IT'S ONE REASON
WHY DRC KELLERMAN OTHER
ADVOCATES HOW TO STEP INTO THE
BREACH SOMEBODY GET CONDITIONS
OF CONFINEMENT IN JAIL SO OFTEN.
OUR STATE STANDARDS IN BSE SICK
I ANSWERED OVERSIGHT- LACKING
JUST SYSTEMS ARE ACTUALLY SET UP
MY LIFE RIGHTS OF PEOPLE IN
CUSTODY. AS SUCH CENTERS ALSO
PROVIDE COVER TO COUNTIES. FOR
EXAMPLE IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN D. R.
C. PUBLISHED REPORT ON CITY OR
COUNTY JAILS. THE RESPONSE ARE
IMPORTANT FINDINGS SAN DIEGO
COUNTY USES COMPLIANCE WITH
TITLE THIRTEEN STANDARDS AS A
SHIELD AGAINST OUR FINDINGS.
MANY OF WHICH ARE RESONATE NEAR
THE CITY AUDITOR'S RECENT
FINDINGS ON THE SAN DIEGO COUNTY
JAIL SYSTEM AS WELL. SEVEN SHORT
WE ENCOURAGE LEGISLATURE TO
DEVELOP AND PUBLISH SPECIFIC
TYPES OF METRICS. TO DETERMINE
WHETHER LOCAL COUNTIES ARE
LIMITING THEIR RELIANCE ON
INCARCERATION AND ATTENTION. WE
RECOMMEND IT TO SAY SERIOUSLY
CONSIDER. COMING UP WITH
ATTRACTIVE SINGLES TO LIMIT THE
USE OF JAILS- FIRST THE STATE
COULD REQUIRE OVERSIGHT BODIES
TO DETERMINE WHETHER LOCAL
COUNTIES ARE EFFECTIVELY
LIMITING SHOW YOU. IN ADDITION
TO THE EXTENSIVE DATA CURRENTLY
COLLECTED BY THE SEC. C. C.
COULD ALSO COLLECT DATA TO
MEASURE WHETHER COUNTIES ARE
DETAINING RESIDENTS THAT COULD
BE BETTER SERVE THE COMMUNITY
OTHER COUNTIES PRACTICES JUST
LIKE IMPACT BLACK AND BLACK AND
WHITE NEXT UNITIES PEOPLE
DISABILITIES. LGBTQ PEOPLE
ESPECIALLY TRANS PEOPLE HE SAYS
HE COULD COLLECT DATA MEASURING
THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE CYCLING IN
AND OUT OF JAILS AND OTHER
INSTITUTIONS BUT THAT SHORT TIME
KOREANS FOR EXAMPLE WHEN YOU'RE
A FINDERS. AND DISAGREE SUCH
INFORMATION BY RACE DISABILITY
LANGUAGE AND OTHER DEMOGRAPHICS.
DSCC CAN ALSO COLLECT DATA
RELATING TO THE EXISTENCE AND
EFFICACY OF PROGRAMS INTENDED TO
DIVERT PEOPLE FROM JAIL
PARTICULAR PROGRAMS FIND IT AT
THE- INTER SUBZERO ONE AND TWO
OF THE FEDERAL SUBSTANCE ABUSE
AND MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
ADMINISTRATION SEQUENTIAL.
INTERCEPT THESE PROGRAMS ARE FOR
AND- OF PROCEEDING AND INSTEAD
OF AN ALTERNATE DISPOSITION TO
ESPECIALLY COURT. SECOND BCC
COMMEMORATES PANDEMIC RELATED
DATA TO CONTINUE TO PUSH FOR
JOHN REDUCTION FROM A PUBLIC
HEALTH PLANS. THIRD THE SEC CAN
ALSO TRACK AN ESCAPED MAJOR
INCIDENTS LIKE DOESN'T BECAUSE
THE SEXUAL SALTS USE THE FORCE.
AS WELL THOUGHT AND USE OF FORCE
AND GENERAL SETTINGS ESPECIALLY
THE USE OF OC SPRAY. HI
PARTICULARLY CONCERNING
JURISDICTIONS FOR ADDITIONAL
MONITORING AND SUPERVISION. THE
FOURTH. AND WE ENCOURAGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO DEVELOP MORE
SPECIFIC REQUIREMENTS TO REQUIRE
INSPECTIONS JUST ASK ON THE
GROUND CONDITIONS WHEN A MORE
REGULAR BASIS THIS IS
NECESSARILY MORE CHALLENGING AND
ASSESSING WHETHER LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS HOW COMPLIANT
POLICIES. BUT WE UNDERSTAND THE
ASSESSING CONDITIONS ARE THE
CORNERSTONE OF EFFECTIVE AND
ADEQUATE OVERSIGHT. WE
UNDERSTAND OUR RECOMMENDATIONS
ARE ALIGNED WITH THE ISSUES
IDENTIFIED BY THE OHIO. AUDITOR
ALONG WITH PLO. IN SHORT IS YOUR
SYSTEM THAT SHOWED THAT THE
STATE SHOULD ENHANCE ITS
OVERSIGHT OVER LOCAL CHANNELS
WITH THE GOAL OF MINIMIZING
JURISDICTIONS RELIANCE ON
JAILING. A SERVICE VISIT
PRESENTER INSTITUTIONS OVERSIGHT
SHOULD NOT NOT EXCESS TELLEMENT
GEL SPINACH LIABILITY TO THE
COVER OF REGULATORY PRESENT
PROVISIONS. THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA ESPECIALLY PEOPLE
THAT DISABILITIES DESERVE NO
LESS THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR LEWIS. AND FINALLY WE'RE
GOING TO HEAR FROM JOHN LINDSAY
POLAND WITH THE AMERICAN FRIENDS
SERVICE COMMITTEE. MR POLAND.
TESTING IN AND THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK MY NAME IS
JOHN LINDSAY POLAND CORRECT
CALIFORNIA HEARING JUSTICE
PROGRAM OF AMERICAN FRIENDS
SERVICE COMMITTEE A QUAKER PEACE
AND JUSTICE ORGANIZATION FOUNDED
IN NINETEEN SEVENTEEN WE CO
AUTHORED AND WITH A WIDE
COALITION OF COMMUNITY GROUPS
ADVOCATED FOR ALAMEDA COUNTY'S
CAREFIRST JAILS LAST POLICY
ADOPTED LAST YEAR. THIS POLICY
LACKS RESOURCES FOR COMMUNITY
BASED MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES.
THAT WOULD HELP KEEP MENTALLY
ILL FOLKS OUT OF JAIL. INSTEAD
JAIL STAFF HAS GROWN IN RESPONSE
TO WHAT'S KNOWN AS A BAD-
LITIGATION. ALAMEDA COUNTY'S
SANTA RITA JAIL HAS THE HIGHEST
NUMBER OF IN CUSTODY DEATHS IN
THE BAY AREA A HIGHER NUMBER
THAN IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY. OF
JAILS IN THE STATE WITH MORE
THAN A THOUSAND COURSE REDID
PERSONS SANTA RITA JAIL HAS THE
HIGHEST PERCENTAGE OF UN
SENTENCED INDIVIDUALS 94%
ACCORDING TO TOM TELL ME ABOUT
IT WHO IS INCARCERATED AND ONE
OF THE JAILS MENTAL HEALTH
UNITS. QUOTE THE WAY THE JAIL IS
ORGANIZED THE CULTURE OF THE
INSTITUTION AND THE ATTITUDE OF
DEPUTIES MAKES IT IMPOSSIBLE TO
ACTUALLY PROVIDE MENTAL HEALTH
CARE. SINCE TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN ALAMEDA COUNTY HAS
RESPONDED TO LITIGATION WITH
INCREASED JAIL STAFF AND
FUNDING. WHICH COINCIDED WITH
THE PANDEMIC AND THE
DRAMATICALLY INCREASED NEED FOR
COMMUNITY BASED MENTAL HEALTH
AND SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
SERVICES. OVER A HUNDRED
PRISONERS FILED OBJECTIONS TO
THE BARBER CONSENT DECREE. AND
DOES AN EDIBLE FOOD AND RECENT
INCREASES IN FOOD COMMISSARY
PRICES HAVE LED THE HUNGER
STRIKES. FAMILIES OF SERIOUSLY
MENTALLY ILL PEOPLE ARE CAMPED
OUT ON THE COUNTY BILLED THE
COUNTY BUILDING DEMANDING FUNDS
FOR HOSPITALS INSTEAD OF JAILS.
WE'RE IN A CRISIS. ARRESTED
INCARCERATION BUT NOT CONVICTION
ARE INDEPENDENTLY ASSOCIATED
WITH POOR MENTAL HEALTH.
INCREASED COUNTY FUNDS FOR JAIL
STAFF HAS UNDERMINED ITS
CAPACITY TO FUND THE COMMUNITY
BASED SERVICES THAT HELP PREVENT
INCARCERATION ARE LESS HARMFUL
THAN JAIL ARE INCREASINGLY
NEEDED DURING THE PANDEMIC AND
ARE ELIGIBLE FOR REIMBURSEMENT
BY FEDERAL AND STATE DOLLARS ON
LIKE JAIL BASED STAFF. WHAT
ABOUT- SETTLEMENT ASSUME TERMS
ASSUME THAT MORE CUSTODY ALL
STAFFED PRIMARILY SHERIFF
DEPUTIES WILL ADDRESS MENTAL
HEALTH NEEDS IN THE JAIL. THE
ASSESSMENT REQUIRES ALAMEDA
COUNTY TO HIRE MORE THAN THREE
TIMES AS MANYNEW SHERIFF'S
STAFF AS BEHAVIORAL HEALTH STUFF
. YEAH EXTREME SHOWS THAT MORE
SHARE STAFF IS UNLIKELY TO
DEEPLY EXACERBATE MENTAL HEALTH
CARE PROBLEMS IN THE JAIL. ONE
EXPERT IN THE BIBLE THAT
OCCASION WROTE THAT THERE WAS NO
EVIDENCE OF EVALUATING IN
CUSTODY DEATHS AND WHAT WOULD
PREVENT THEM. THIS LACK OF
INSTRUCTOR INTROSPECTION HAS PER
PROVED DEADLY. MORE SHARE STAFF
DOES NOT COMPENSATE FOR THE LACK
OF MENTAL HEALTH STAFF. YET NO
STRATEGIES FOR PROVIDING
CONSTITUTIONAL LEVELS OF MENTAL
HEALTH CARE BY REDUCING THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE INCARCERATED IN
JAIL OR EVEN REFERENCED IN THE
BIBLE DECREE. COUNTY BUDGETS
LIKE- ALL ACROSS THE STATE COVER
SERVICES BOTH IN THE COMMUNITY
AND IN JAILS BUT ALAMEDA COUNTY
LIKE OTHER COUNTIES MAKES POLICY
AND BUDGETS FOR MENTAL HEALTH
CARE IN THE JAIL SEPARATELY FROM
THE CARE AND SERVICES NEEDED
OUTSIDE THE GYM. WHEN THE COUNTY
IS SUED FOR POOR CONDITIONS IN
THE JAIL AND MEASURES TO DENVER
OR DIVERT ARRESTS IMPROVE MENTAL
HEALTH OUTSIDE THE JAIL AND
REDUCE THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE
BEHIND BARS ARE NOT ON THE
TABLE. ONLY CONDITIONS IN JAIL
ARE. STATE FUNDING FOR BSE SEE
ANYTHING MORE STATE FUNDING FOR
COMMUNITY BASED SERVICES. AND
INFLUENCE THIS BALKANIZATION OF
SERVICES FOR PEOPLE WITH MENTAL
ILLNESSES AND MENTAL ILLNESS THE
PLACE IS CLEAN RESOURCES FOR
DETAILS ABOUT HOUSING HOSPITALS
AND OTHER SERVICES OUTSIDE THE
JAIL. TRANSPARENCY OF GEL
EXPENDITURES IS FUNDAMENTALLY
LACKING. THE COUNTY HAS
DEDICATED INCREASINGLY LARGE
PORTIONS OF ITS GENERAL FUND TO
ADDITIONAL CUSTODIAL AND
CLINICAL STAFF IN THE JAIL- BUT
THE NUMBER OF FUNDED VACANCIES
AT THE JAIL HAS ONLY GROWN. IF
THERE'S NO TRANSPARENT
ACCOUNTING OF WHAT HAPPENS ON
EXPENDED FUNDS ALLOCATED TO JAIL
STAFF. NOR IS THERE ANY
TRANSPARENT FUNGIBILITY OF AN
EXPANDED FUNDS THAT COULD BE
MOVED INTO BADLY NEEDED
COMMUNITY BASED SERVICES FOR THE
SAME POPULATION OF SERIOUSLY
MENTALLY ILL PEOPLE WHO ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY SPEND TIME IN
THE JAIL AND SENTENCED.
MANDATING THAT TYPE OF
TRANSPARENCY IS URGENTLY NEEDED.
IN LINE WITH THE RECOMMENDATIONS
YOU JUST HEARD THE SEC COULD
MANDATE AND SOME DEVICE PRETRIAL
ASSESSMENTS AND RELEASE THAT
BOOKING DISCHARGE PLANNING
MENTAL HEALTH ASSESSMENT BODY
BOOKING METHADONE TREATMENT
OVERSIGHT OF COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH AGENCIES AND THE AMOUNT
OF PROGRAM TIME PEOPLE IN JAIL
GET. THERE IS NOT ADEQUATE
OVERSIGHT OF HOW HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF REALIGNMENT DOLLARS
ARE SPENT AND WHAT THEY SHOULD
BE SPENT ON. IN ALAMEDA COUNTY
FOR EXAMPLE THE SEC FINES HAVE
NOT IMPROVED OUTCOMES FORGET IT
CONDITIONS INSIDE PREVENTED
DEATHS OR IMPROVE RETENTION. IT
WOULD BE A SHAME IF REFORMS TO
BE S. YOU SEE ONLY RESULTED IN
MORE RESOURCES FOR JAILS TO
IMPROVING THE STATE OF JAILS
INSTEAD OF THE HEALTH OF THE
PEOPLE IN THEM. I URGE YOU TO
MANDATE ACCOUNTABILITY
HOLISTICALLY. IN WAYS THAT DON'T
JUST POUR MORE FUNDS INTO JAILS
AND THE STRUCTURES THAT OPERATE
THEM. BUT IT JUST NEEDS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES THAT PROMOTE HEALING
AND PREVENT FURTHER
INCARCERATION THANK YOU SO MUCH.
FOR THANK YOU MR POLAND PRE
SHAPE YOUR TIME BEING WITH US
TODAY- THAT'S THE END OF OUR
PANEL- I JUST WANT TO OPEN IT UP
TO. OUR COLLEAGUES HERE YES
SENATOR CURTIS. THANK YOU
MINIATURE- I JUST WANNA I'VE
BEEN TELLING MYSELF TO JUST
FOCUS ON KEEPING THEM. MIKE
COMMENT COMMENTS IN QUESTION
CONCISE HERE BECAUSE- I WRITE
HERE IS SORT OF MY COLLEAGUES
KNOW. JUST BARELY OVER A YEAR
AGO FROM SANTA CLARA COUNTY.
HELLO I'M IN A- HAVE BEEN
IMMERSED IN THESE ISSUES- ON THE
LOCAL JAIL SEEN FIRST HAND FOR A
LONG TIME. THAT SAID- I WANT TO
THANK ALL THE PRISONERS I THINK
EVERYONE WHO PRESENTED- THUS FAR
IN THIS PANEL- HAD A LOT OF GOOD
THINGS TO SAY AND A LOT OF
THINGS THAT SHOULD BE. PURSUED-
THAT SAID- I AGREE MOST WITH THE
LAST PRISONER. HELLO JOHN
LINDSAY POLAND HOME BECAUSE I
THINK THERE'S A FUNDAMENTAL
PROBLEM IN AN ISSUE THAT WE HAVE
HERE IS THAT WE'RE STILL
TREATING. OF MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES BEHAVIOR HEALTH ISSUES-
ON A CRIMINAL PLATFORM. IN I
THINK THAT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT
CALIFORNIA ALONE IS GUILTY OF I
THINK THAT'S PROBABLY BEEN GOING
ON SINCE ALEXANDER THE GREAT-
BUT- THE CALIFORNIA COULD BE THE
FIRST DATE. THAT MAKES THE SHIFT
- FROM TREATING MEDICAL ISSUES
TO TREATING MEDICAL ISSUES HAS
MEDICAL ISSUES AND CRIMINAL
ISSUES AS CRIMINAL ISSUES. IN
OUR COUNTY- HELLO IS MR
PROSPECTOR KNOWS A CAME IN AND-
AND I THINK ULTIMATELY DID. A
GOOD THING IN TERMS OF OPENING
UP. THE TRANSPARENCY AROUND WHAT
WAS GOING ON IN THE JAILS. PART
WAY THROUGH PILLOWS ANALYSIS
WITH THE DEATH OF. A YOUNG MAN
NAMED MICHAEL TYREE WHO WAS IN
JAIL ACCORDING TO THE JUDGE WHO
. WHO SENT HIM THERE FOR ONE
REASON AND ONE REASON ONLY
BECAUSE HE HAD A MENTAL HEALTH
CONDITION- IN THERE WERE NO BEDS
. AND SO THE JUDGE THOUGHT
PUTTING HIM IN JAIL WAS OPENED
AND PUT HIM ON THE STREET ON A
SHORT TERM BASIS. INITIAL OPENLY
WASN'T EQUIPPED NUMBER ONE TO
DEAL WITH HIM. IN HIS CONDITION
AND NUMBER TWO. IN THAT
PARTICULAR CASE- THE GUARDS
THEMSELVES WERE WERE SENTENCED
ON THAT WAS UNPREDICTABLE
SENTENCED FOR MURDER IN THAT
CASE. BUT WHAT'S WHAT WAS
PREDICTABLE I THINK IS AFFECTED
IN A JAIL SYSTEM AND I BELIEVE
THIS IS HAPPENING ACROSS THE
BOARD WE'RE HEARING ABOUT THAT
WORK. 49% IN IN OUR SYSTEM. OF
49% OF THE INMATES. WITH THE
CURRENT CENSUS OF TWENTY FOUR
HUNDRED IN THE JAILS DOWN THERE
FORTY NINE PERCENT. ARE
CLINICALLY DIAGNOSED MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES UP UPON INTAKE- IN
THE COUNTY STILL STRUGGLING I
THINK TO. COMPORT WITH THE
CONSENT DECREE THAT WAS. SECURED
BY PRISON OFFICE- BUT WAS EVEN
MORE STRIKING IS. THAT AND I
THINK IT WAS BROUGHT UP ON THE
LAST PRISONER I THINK OUR STATE
SYSTEM IS STILL GEARED. TOWARD
FUNDING AND REIMBURSING WEEK WE
DEALT WITH THAT- WE'VE DEALT
WITH THAT HERE IN THE IN THE
COMMITTEE YOU KNOW OVER THE LAST
COUPLE YEARS- THIS FOCUS ON ON
FINDING. A CREAM HELLO GRANT
OPPORTUNITIES FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENT SOMEONE TO BUILD
ADDITIONAL JAIL SPACE- TO DEAL
WITH. THE CENTURY BOTH
POPULATIONS- CRIMINAL UNDYED
MOST POPULATION IN THIS
POPULATION THAT. I WOULD SAY
FIRST AND FOREMOST IS THERE
BECAUSE HE'S BEEN DIAGNOSED WITH
A CLINICAL MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES
OR TOOL DIAGNOSED WITH FROM
OTHER BUILDER HOPING HERE HEALTH
ISSUES. LIKE DRUG ALCOHOL- SO I
WOULD LIKE TO HEAR YEAH I HEARD
AND APPRECIATED ASSISTED
EVERYONE. WHO SPOKE. IN
DISABILITY RIGHTS STARTED GOING
DOWN THIS PATH OF I THOUGHT OF.
YOU KNOW THE LEGISLATURE COULD.
COULD PUT SOME MORE SIGNIFICANT
GUIDELINES IN PLACE- WHEN I LOOK
AT BSE SEE HERE THE REPORT SAYS
THAT IF WE INCREASED. YOU KNOW
JUST RECENTLY AS TWENTY TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWENTY TWO. FOURTEEN
ADDITIONAL POSITIONS SO THAT
INSPECTIONS COULD BE DONE AT
LEAST ANNUALLY. AND I DON'T KNOW
I GUESS ONE QUESTION I HAVE IS
THAT THE CAPACITY OF BSE SEE
BECAUSE I THINK WE'RE- SORT OF
JUST CHASING OUR TAILS OF WE'RE
GONNA SAY PSEC NEEDS TO DO MORE
AND THEY NEED TO HAVE MORE. MORE
GUIDELINES AND- IN A FEW MORE
SEATS ON THE BOARD AND- IN THEY
JUST THEY JUST NEED TO PAY MORE
ATTENTION WHEN THEY'RE DOING
THESE INSPECTIONS. OF THE ONLY
HAVE. ANOTHER PEOPLE TO DO ONE
INSPECTION A YEAR. WITH WIND
CHILL CONDITIONS ARE THIS BAD.
IT THEN THE MODEL ITSELF IS A
FAILURE IN IT AGAIN I DON'T
CRITICIZE I'M NOT CRITICIZING
PSEC IN THE LEADERSHIP THERE I'M
SAYING THIS THIS MODEL WAS SET
UP IN A WAY OBVIOUSLY THAT
DOESN'T HAVE THE CAPACITY TO. TO
COME ANYWHERE NEAR THE OVERSIGHT
NEEDED FOR THE PROBLEM I THINK
WE'RE HEARING THAT TODAY BUT-
ARE WE JUST GONNA SORT OF. WAIT
AND SEE IF THESE FOURTEEN
POSITIONS TURN THE WHOLE SYSTEM
AROUND. I DON'T THINK THAT'S
GOING TO DO IT. IN IN A CERTAIN
CITY DISABILITY RIGHTS YOU KNOW
TALKING ABOUT GUIDELINES AS A
WAY THE LEGISLATURE COULD COULD
GUIDE. A TRANSITION TOWARD
REDUCING CAR SERRATION HOW ABOUT
FUNDING IN OUR GREATESTPOWER
IS. IS THE BUDGET HERE AND- THE
END IT WOULD POSE A QUESTION I
JUST THE MONKS OR COLLEAGUES AND
YOU COULD TAKE IT AS A
RHETORICAL QUESTION FOR NOW I
DON'T KNOW THAT ANYONE WILL
RESPOND TO IT- I THINK. MR
LINDSAY POLAND HAS ALREADY
RESPONDED TO A DEFENSE BUT WHY
AREN'T WE HI WHY ARE WE SHIFTING
BUDGET DOLLARS IS QUICKLY AND A
SIGNIFICANT WE SEE AS WE CAN
THAT WOULD GO DOWNSTREAM FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE TO BUILD MENTAL
HEALTH TREATMENT CENTERS INSTEAD
OF JAILS IN OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES- IN WHY WOULDN'T WE
DO EVERYTHING WE POSSIBLY COULD
TO DIS INCENTIVIZE COUNTIES.
LIKE SANTA CLARA COUNTY WAS JUST
APPROVED ANOTHER FIVE HUNDRED
BED. ALL TEN MILLION DOLLAR
JAIL. FOR A POPULATION THAT IS
ALMOST 50% MENTAL HEALTH
PATIENTS- IT'S AUTOMATICALLY AN
ADA VIOLATION I THINK TO TREAT
SOMEONE FOR A MENTAL HEALTH
CONDITION IN A JAIL HEY I JUST
DON'T KNOW HOW TO GET AROUND
THAT. SO- ANYWAY I GUESS AS THEY
SAY THAT'S HOW I REALLY FEEL-
BUT GIVEN THAT WE'RE A BUDGET
COMMITTEE I DID WANT TO JUST PUT
THIS LARGER ISSUE OUT THERE I
THINK IT'S- I THINK IT'S- THE
ELEPHANT IN THE ROOM. WHAT ARE
WE DOING OR WHAT ARE WE GOING TO
DO- TO DRAMATICALLY SHIFT
FUNDING TO REALLY REPRESENT- THE
POPULATION. OR IF YOU WORK WITH
THE INTAKE OF THE POPULATION THE
INTAKE OF THE GILLS NOW A
BLESSING I WANTED TO SAY WAS
RELATIVE TO. THE EXAMPLE OF MY
OWN HOME COUNTY. THE NUMBERS
THAT WE HEARD ABOUT SANTA RITA
94% AND SENTENCED. I HAVE THE
LETTER I REFERENCED IT A COUPLE
WEEKS AGO. FROM THE C. O. O. IN
SANTA CLARA COUNTY MCGILL MARK
AS A SERVICE OF TWENTY FOUR
HUNDRED THE TWENTY FOUR HUNDRED
JILL CENSUS IN OUR OWN COUNTY
RIGHT NOW- THE MAJORITY HAVE
BEEN THERE. FOR ELEVEN MONTHS
AWAITING. AWAITING A COURT DATE
AWAITING A COURT DATE OF YOU
EXTRAPOLATE THAT BACK TO THE
PERCENTAGE THAT ARE THERE
BECAUSE OF MENTAL HEALTH
PROBLEMS IT MEANS THAT YOU HAVE
MENTAL HEALTH PATIENTS
BASICALLY. TWELVE HUNDRED OF
THEM WITHIN THE PERCENTAGES ARE
RIGHT HALF OF THOSE TWELVE
HUNDRED INDIVIDUALS WITH MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES- STUCK IN JAIL
CELLS AWAITING A COURT
APPEARANCE- YOU KNOW IT IT'S
UNCONSCIONABLE BUT IT ALSO HE
ALSO SAID THAT IF YOU READ
REMOVE THE BACKLOG THEY'D ONLY
BE FOUR HUNDRED INDIVIDUALS LEFT
INCARCERATED IN THE ADULT IN THE
INTERREGIONAL SYSTEM SO- WELL.
WE HAVE A LOT OF WORK TO DO BUT
THESE. THESE ISSUES THESE ISSUES
ARE INTERTWINED AND I THINK
UNTIL WE START BUILDING SEPARATE
FACILITIES. FOR THE FOLKS WHO
NEED HEALTH CARE- BUT I JUST
DON'T SPELL JUST I THINK WE'RE
NIBBLING AROUND THE EDGES. UNTIL
WE DO THAT ANYWAY THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNISTIC FOR A FEW MINUTES
. THANK YOU- THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SENATOR I THINK THE- PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE THAT YOU SHARED ON
THE LOCAL LEVEL- IT IS VERY
IMPORTANT AS WE LOOK AT. WHAT
WE'RE GONNA DO WITH THAT AT THE
STATEWIDE LEVEL. CENTER NEWMAN
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. IT'S
A LOT A LOT TOO LET'S. BUT LIKE
TO TAKE IN- I HAVE A QUESTION
FOR MR- THE POLAND. HELLO I'M
SORRY WITH MISTER SPECTER- DID
YOU HAVE I DIDN'T HEAR FROM YOU
IF YOU HAD ANY SPECIFIC-
PRIORITY RECOMMENDATIONS I'M
SURE YOU HAVE A LOT OF. BUT ARE
THERE ANY FOCUSED
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT YOU WOULD
MAKE TO US. IF HE'S STILL ON.
CLICK IT LET ME NOT BE. MAYBE WE
CAN ASK HIM TO STAY ON. OKAY.
SHE.
WITH RESPECT- IF YOU'RE STILL ON
MAYBE ON MUTE- I'M SOME SORRY
COULD. I WAS A DISTRACTED FOR A
MOMENT IS THERE A QUESTION I AM
WRITING I JUST HAD A QUESTION IF
YOU HAD ANY- SPECIFIC. PRIORITY
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT YOU WOULD
MAKE TO US. WELL ACTUALLY I
AGREE WITH- THE CONSULTANT'S
REPORT- AND I AGREE WITH ALL THE
OTHER PANELISTS- I THINK IN
ORDER OF PRIORITY I THINK. YOU
CAN'T. DO ANYTHING WITHOUT
DECENT POLICIES AND PROCEDURES
SO THAT REGULATIONS- I THINK WE
REALLY NEED A LOT OF WORK- THEY
NEED THEY NEED. PEOPLE WHO HAVE
EXPERTISE IN BOTH THE OPERATIONS
OF JAILS AND ALSO EXPERTISE AND-
CONSTITUTIONAL STANDARDS AND
THEN AND- ALSO EXPERTISE IN THE
AMERICANS WITH DISABILITY ACT TO
HELP THE BSE CITY DRAFT DECENT
REGULATIONS WE- HAVE ABOUT TEN
YEARS AGO WE TRIED TO GET.
REGULATED WE TRIED TO AND
INFLUENCE THE REGULATIONS WHEN
THEY WERE BEING REVIEWED IN
TERMS OF- THE THERE ARE
REGULATIONS ON SOLITARY
CONFINEMENT IN EVERY SINGLE ONE
OF OUR OUR PROPOSALS WAS
REJECTED. NO I DON'T BLAME OF
COURSE THE CURRENT BORDER OR
MISS HOWARD AT ALL BUT SINCE SHE
WASN'T THERE BUT- UNTIL THE
REGULATIONS GET- IMPROVED AND
THEY GET SPECIFIC- THEN THEY
CAN'T MONITOR ANYTHING. SO THAT
WOULD BE MY FIRST PRIORITY IN
THE SECOND PRIORITY WOULD BE TO
. MAKE SURE THEY HAVE SUBJECT
MATTER EXPERTS INVOLVED IN BOTH
THE INSPECTION PROCESS AND THE-
REGULATORY PROCESS OKAY. THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISS
HOWARD OR WOULD ANYONE LIKE TO
RESPOND TO. ANY OF THE TESTIMONY
THAT WE JUST HEARD. THANK YOU SO
MUCH SENATOR THIS IS KATIE
HOWARD I'M GONNA MENTION A FEW
THINGS AND THEN ASK MY COLLEAGUE
ALLISON- TO PLEASE CHIME IN AS
WELL. UNDER MR SPECTER'S MOST
RECENT COMMENTS WE HAVE A VERY
PUBLIC AND TRANSPARENT PROCESS
FOR THE WORK THAT WE DO ON
REGULATION REVISIONS- WE ALWAYS
REQUEST SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTS
TO PARTICIPATE ALLISON CAN.
READILY PULL UP THE NAMES AND
AFFILIATIONS THAT THE SUBJECT
MATTER EXPERTS WHO PARTICIPATED
ON OUR LAST EXECUTIVE STEERING
COMMITTEE THAT. JUST RECENTLY
COMPLETED OUR BOARD APPROVED.
REVISED REGULATIONS IN NOVEMBER
OF LAST YEAR THEY'RE NOW GOING
THROUGH THAT- STERNBACH PROCESS-
AND ARE. ABOUT TO BE FINALIZED-
I KNOW IN SOME SPECIFIC ISSUES
THAT HAVE BEEN TALKED ABOUT
TODAY- I DON'T REPORT ON SAN
DIEGO- TOUCHED ON SOME OF THE
DETAILS IN THE REGULATION. YOU
CHECKS- THERE WAS SOME
ADDITIONAL- SPECIFICITY ADDED IN
THE LAST UPDATE TO THAT
REGULATION- JUST TO. MAKE IT
MORE CLEAR AND I THINK THAT THAT
THE PRACTICE OUT CLEARLY IS THAT
IT'S IT IS THE JOB IT IS THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF THE PERSON
DOING THE SAME TO CHAT. TO BE
DETERMINING THAT THE PERSON IS
ALIVE HE GETS INTO A HOLE I MEAN
I'LL JUST MENTION THIS BRIEFLY I
KNOW WE DON'T WANT TO GET OVERLY
OVERLY GRANULAR BUT THERE'S ALSO
BEEN LITIGATION IN THE PAST-
CONCERNING PEOPLE BEING WOKEN
UP. DURING THE NIGHT YOU KNOW
MULTIPLE TIMES AS PART OF A
SAFETY CHECK TO DETERMINE THAT
PEOPLE ARE ALIVE I MEAN YOU HAVE
TO FIND A BALANCED. AND
REASONABLE SPOT TO LAND. PURPOSE
OF THIS FEATURE IS. THE SAFETY
AND WELL BEING OF THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE IN THE FACILITY AND BATS
RACE I JUST MENTION DETERMINE
THE SAFETY AND WELL BEING. WE
BELIEVE STANDS FOR IS A LOT. IS
NOT IN DISTRESS IS NOT HAVING A
MEDICAL ISSUE OR ANY OTHER
METHOD MEDICAL OR MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES THAT COULD NEED
IMMEDIATE. ATTENTION SO- I WOULD
SAY. FIRST COUPLE OF THOUGHTS
ARE WE ABSOLUTELY WORK
EXTENSIVELY WITH SUBJECT MATTER
EXPERTS IN THE DEVELOPMENT AND
UPDATES TO OUR REGULATIONS. ONE
OF THE OTHER POINTS MISTER
SPECTER TALKED ABOUT WAS THAT
THERE SHOULD BE SUBJECT MATTER
EXPERTS INVOLVED IN THE
INSPECTIONS THEMSELVES. AND IT
COMES TO THE DELIVERY OF THE
HEALTH CARE OF THE JAILS IT I
THE COUNTY HEALTH. DEPARTMENT
THAT CONDUCTS AN ANNUAL
INSPECTION SO. SOME OF THE OF
THE INFORMATION HAS BEEN
PROVIDED- HERE TODAY DOESN'T
SQUARE. WITH ACTUAL PRACTICE.
THE OTHER THING- THERE THERE'S A
LOT MORE THAT WE SHOULD SAY BUT
I JUST WANTED TO CLEAR ONE OTHER
ITEM OF CONFUSION WE DID INCLUDE
THIS IN OUR- OUR RESPONSE LETTER
TO THE AUDIT. I BELIEVE THE
AUDITOR HAS A MISUNDERSTANDING
WHEN IT SAYS THAT THE CDC ARE
REGULATIONS. ON SAFETY CHECKS
REQUIRES THE PERSON DOING THE
INSPECTION TO DETERMINE THAT THE
PERSON IS ALIVE. THE SPECIFIC
CITATION THAT THEY MADE COMES
FROM THE CDC OUR OPERATIONS
MANUAL. AND THAT SECTION IS NOT
PERTAINING TO SAFETY CHECKS
INSTEAD IT'S PERTAINING TO DOING
AN ACTUAL COUNT. OF THE NUMBER
OF PEOPLE IN FACILITY AND IT'S A
REGULATION THAT SAYS. THAT THEY
ARE TO COUNT BOTH LIVING
BREATHING INDIVIDUALS AND SOME
OF THE STUFF IS REALLY. HARSH TO
HAVE TO TALK ABOUT THAT THAT
MEANS THAT THEY CAN'T COUNT DEAD
PEOPLE IN THE POPULATION YEAH
THAT'S THAT'S WHAT THAT IS IT
DOESN'T HAVE TO DO WITH THE
SAFETY CHECK. SO OBVIOUSLY IS A
VERY DIFFICULT SET OF ISSUES-
THOSE ARE SOME OF THE SPECIFIC
ISSUES I WANTED TO MENTION A
THOUSAND IF YOU WOULDN'T MIND-
TALKING ABOUT. SOME OF THE
SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTS ON OUR
LAST MANY. SURE THANK YOU KATIE
I'LL JANNEY WITH YES SEE OUR
LAST REGULATION RIGHT- EXECUTIVE
STEERING. WE OUTSIDE- WITH A
VARIETY OF LIVED EXPERIENCE AND
COMMUNITY COMMUNITY. ADVOCACY
INCLUDING AN ATTORNEY FROM THE
DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA. WE
ALSO HAD- A COUNTY COUNCIL
MEMBER WE ALSO HAD A PERSON WHO
WORKS IN CORRECTIONAL HEALTH
CARE AND A PERSON WHO WORKS IN
SH CORRECTIONAL MENTAL HEALTH
CARE SO WE DID COVER THOSE-
AREAS OF SUBJECT MATTER
EXPERTISE IN THAT THE REGULATION
REVISION PROCESS. AND JUST TO
ECHO- WHAT- KATIE TALKED ABOUT
IS THAT- D. HEALTH AND SAFETY
CODE REQUIRES THAT THE COUNTY
HEALTHDEPARTMENT CONDUCT ANNUAL
INSPECTIONS OF EACH PLACE OF
DETENTION CENTER WHICH IN OUR
REGULATIONS WE HAVE A SECTION ON
MEDICAL MENTAL HEALTH WE HAVE A
SECTION ON NUTRITIONAL HEALTH WE
ALSO HAVE A SECTION. ON
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH. AND SO
SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTS FROM EACH
OF THOSE THREE AREAS GO INTO THE
DETENTION FACILITIES THEY
INSPECT FOR THOSE PARTICULAR
REGULATIONS AND ALSO ANY
OPERATIONAL REGULATIONS THAT
MIGHT CROSS OVER- SO- THINGS
HAVING TO DO WITH SUICIDE
PREVENTION OR- OR SAFETY CELLS
OR OTHER HIGH RISK AREAS SO-
THOSE INSPECTIONS ARE BEING
CONDUCTED AND THEY ARE BEING
CONDUCTED THE ANNUAL THE- ANNUAL
EITHER REQUIRED TO SUBMIT THOSE
TO. US AS PART OF OUR INSPECTION
REPORTS. OKAY. IS THAT IT MAY
MISS HOWARD. WELL I HAVE OKAY
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH I JUST
WANNA- ASKED LMAO WHAT OPTIONS
DO INCARCERATED UP PEOPLE AND
THEIR FAMILIES HAVE FOR RAISING.
ISSUES ABOUT JAIL CONDITIONS ARE
ESPECIALLY IN COUNTIES THAT
DON'T HAVE- ON LOCAL INSPECTOR
GENERAL OR OVERSIGHT BOARDS. I
BELIEVE THAT MOST COUNTIES IF
NOT ALL WOULD OPERATE SOME FORM
OF GRIEVANCE SYSTEM THROUGH
WHICH- INMATES COULD FILE
COMPLAINTS- THE DETAILS OF THAT
WOULD BE- COULD VARY BY COUNTY-
AND IT'S POSSIBLE THAT THE SEC
MAY HAVE SOME MORE INFORMATION
ON HOW THAT LOOKS IN PRACTICE-
IT TO MAKE IT IN TERMS OF.
RAISING ISSUES THAT I WOULD BE
IN ORDER TO RAISE CONCERNS TO-
THE FACILITY ADMINISTRATORS- IN
THEIR COUNTY I HAD TO THE EGGS
IF YOU'RE REFERRING TO HOW
PEOPLE CAN RAISE CONCERNS TO THE
SEC OR TO THE STATE MARK
BRADLEY- THERE ISN'T AS FAR AS
I'VE- EVER COME ACROSS AN
OFFICIAL INTAKE SYSTEM FOR. THE
SEC TO RECEIVE REPORTED STANDARD
VIOLATIONS ARE CONCERNS- FROM
INMATES OR THEIR FAMILIES- THE-
AS YOU WILL RECALL THERE IS A-
OMBUDSPERSON- BEING. DEVELOPED
ON THE JUVENILE SIGN WHICH COULD
SERVE AS A MODEL FOR- FOR SUCH A
SYSTEM OUR- OPERATE WITH RESPECT
TO ADULT LOCAL DETENTION
FACILITIES- BUT- HAVE TO BE SEC
COULDN'T SPEAK TOWARD- SPEAK IN
MORE DETAIL UNLESS I DO KNOW
THAT- FAMILIES TEND TO COLIN TO
BE SEC MEETINGS TO EXPRESS
CONCERNS AND- JUST FROM MY OWN
OBSERVATION- AS WELL AS-
SUBMITTING. INFORMATION TO- THE
EXECUTIVE STEERING COMMITTEES
AND WORKING GROUPS THAT ARE
REVISING THE STANDARDS SO THERE
IS A PROCESS FOR IN TAKING.
COMMENT PUBLIC COMMENTS ON THAT
. LET ME KNOW IF I'M NOT
ANSWERING YOUR QUESTION WELL
MAYBE MISS HOWARD COULD ANSWER.
IN ADDITION TO WHAT YOU SAID.
YES I JUST WANT TO BESURE I'M
UNDERSTANDING THE NATURE OF YOUR
QUESTION SENATOR I BELIEVE YOU
SAID WHAT IS THE PROCESS FOR A
PERSON WHO IS INCARCERATED OR
FAMILY MEMBERS TO RAISE CONDUCT
CONCERNS ABOUT THE CONDITIONS OF
CONFINEMENT. IF THEY DON'T HAVE
THE LOCAL LOCAL. AND I WILL- ASK
ALAN SAID TO ADD TO THIS BUT-
EACH AND EVERY FACILITY DOES
HAVE SOME SORT OF A GRIEVANCE
PROCEDURE- AND- YOU CAN'T LAND
IS ABSOLUTELY CORRECT WE HEAR
EXTENSIVELY AND OUR MANY
OPPORTUNITIES FOR PUBLIC COMMENT
PUBLIC INPUT AND LISTENING
SESSIONS AND THIS IS
PARTICULARLY. AN ISSUE DURING
PARTICULARLY THE FIRST SEVERAL
MONTHS OF THAT. CALL THE
PANDEMIC THERE WERE HUGE
CONCERNS FROM FAMILY MEMBERS AND
CONCERNING REPORTS COMING OUT
OF. JAIL FACILITIES ABOUT WHAT
WAS GOING ON AND ACCESS TO. HE
P. IAN HOW COLD CASES WERE BEING
ADDRESSED SO- WE CERTAINLY TOOK
SOME ACTION STEPS IN RESPONSE TO
THOSE KINDS OF CONCERNS COMING
AND SO- WHERE THE BOARD CAN DO
MORE WE CERTAINLY DO AND-
THOUSAND WOULD YOU PLEASE ADD ON
JUST IN TERMS OF THE GENERAL
QUESTION ABOUT WHAT A PERSON CAN
DO- WITH THE SORTS OF CONCERNS.
SURE K. THANK YOU- CERTAINLY
EVERY DETENTION FACILITY HAS A
PROCESS FOR GRIEVANCES THEY ALSO
HAVE PROCESS USED FOR- CITIZEN'S
COMPLAINT IS THAT OUR NEXT
TECHNICALLY USED. ON THOSE
PROCESSES CAN BE FOUND ON EACH
ARM AN AGENCY'S WEBSITE
TYPICALLY AND THAT THE AGENCY
HAS POLICIES AND PROCEDURES TO
ADDRESS THOSE- WHILE WE DON'T
HAVE- AS MENTIONED A FORMAL
PROCESS TO RECEIVE. COMPLAINTS
FROM- INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
CONCERNED WITH- PRACTICES THAT
FACILITIES WE DO GET THEM. AND
WE DO RESPOND TO THEM- AS AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE- BUT BUT-
TYPICALLY IF PEOPLE HAVE
CONCERNS THEY GO THROUGH THE
AGENCY IS- CITIZEN COMPLAINT
PROCESS OR A PERSON HOUSED IN
THE FACILITY WOULD GO. TO THE
FACILITIES GRIEVANCE PROCESS.
OKAY AND LAST WEEK WE MOVE ON-
OF OUR PANELISTS I THINK EACH
ONE OF THEM OF THAT SPOKE ABOUT
THE NUMBER AND THE PERCENTAGE
OF- INCARCERATED PEOPLE. WHO'LL
HAVE MEANT ARE YOU KNOW HAVE A
MENTAL ILLNESS OF MENTAL. HEALTH
ISSUES BEHAVIOR HEALTH ISSUES.
ARE THAT THE PERCENTAGE APPEARS
TO BE GROWING IT OR IT'S ALREADY
SIGNIFICANTLY HIGH. AND THAT
THEY'RE NOT GETTING THE SERVICES
INSIDE THAT THEY NEED AND COULD
ONLY GET WORSE. WHAT DO YOU ALL
SAY TO THAT BECAUSE THAT'S SEEMS
TO BE A VERY- COMMON ISSUE THAT
WAS RAISED BY EVERYONE. IF I MAY
MADAM CHAIR WAS WITHOUT QUESTION
TO THE PANEL YES I'M SORRY OKAY
YOU TOO THIS IS KATIE HARD WITH
THE BSE THIS. THE GOVERNOR AND
THIS LEGISLATURE HAS MADE SOME
PRETTY SIZEABLE INVESTMENTS IN
IN LAST YEAR'S BUDGET TO BETTER
ADDRESS- BEHAVIORAL HEALTH NEEDS
IN THE COUNTIES JUST AS ONE
EXAMPLE- AS YOU'RE AWARE OVER
THE LAST. TEN OR TWELVE YEARS OR
SO- THERE THE STATE HAS MADE A
FAIRLY SIZEABLE INVESTMENT IN.
IMPROVEMENT OF JAIL FACILITIES-
AND LAST YEAR. PRIOR TO THE
RELEASE OF THE JANUARY BUDGET
BUDGET- WE WERE ASKED FOR
INFORMATION ABOUT THE AMOUNT OF
FUNDING THAT HAD BEEN
RELINQUISHED BY COUNTIES THAT
WERE NOT. FOR ONE REASON OR
ANOTHER NOT ABLE TO COMPLETE
THEIR CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS
PLANNED AND WAS I THINK ABOUT
TWO HUNDRED AND EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS THAT WAS IN ESSENCE ON
THE TABLE WHAT THE GOVERNOR IN
HIS PROPOSAL SWEPT THAT FINDING.
AS PART OF A MUCH LARGER
FINANCIAL INVESTMENT IN COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH SERVICES AND
FACILITIES THERE IS A GREAT DEAL
IN PROCESS- IN THIS REGARD THAT
I KNOW WHETHER PEOPLE HAVE A LOT
MORE DETAILED INFORMATION ABOUT
BUT- WE CAN CERTAINLY PUT
TOGETHER SOME INFORMATION AND
FOLLOW UP FOR YOU. BECAUSE THAT
THAT WORK IS REALLY IMPORTANT
YOU KNOW I THINK IT'S ABSOLUTELY
TRUE- THE CONCERNS ARE VERY
LEGITIMATE ABOUT PEOPLE WHO. ARE
IN COUNTY JAILS AND WHERE THEIR
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES ARE NOT
ABLE TO BE SUFFICIENTLY
ADDRESSED. AND IN ADDITION I
GUESS I WOULD ALSO MENTION THAT
THE SEC ADMINISTERS MANY
DIFFERENT GRANTS AND- SOME OF
THOSE GRANT PROGRAMS OVER THE
YEARS HAVE SPECIFICALLY FOCUSED
ON. DIVERSION PROGRAM SET THEN
THE NAME IS OUT OF DATE AT THIS
POINT BUT A FEW YEARS AGO THERE
WAS THAT MENTALLY ILL OFFENDERS
CRIME REDUCTION PROGRAM THAT WAS
EXACTLY WHAT- EIGHTY LEWIS FROM
DISABILITY RIGHTS COUNCIL WAS
TALKING ABOUT IT SAID- SET MODEL
IT'S A- DIVERSION. PROGRAM SO
THERE CERTAINLY ARE OTHER THINGS
THAT CAN BE INVESTED IN AND SOME. OF WHICH THE SEC HAS BEEN. AT
OVER YEARS. THANK YOU FOR I WILL
ON I JUST COMMENT THAT- BASED ON
THE- TESTIMONY OF THE VARIOUS-
PANELISTS WHO WERE HERE TODAY
THEY CERTAINLY RAISE ALL THESE
ISSUES OUT OF CARE AND CONCERN
FOR THE SAFETY OF- THOSE WHO ARE
IN THE FACILITIES. AND ALSO FOR
THE STAFF OF THE FACILITIES
BECAUSE NOBODY SHOULD FEEL THAT
THEY'RE IN ANY KIND OF DANGER-
WITH THE WITH THE CONDITIONS OUT
THERE AND- SO I'M REALLY
CONCERNED BECAUSE- THERE'S ALL
THIS LITIGATION THAT HAPPENS WE
END UP HAVING TO ADDRESS IT
ANYWAY. HAVING TO CORRECT IT-
AND YET. WE NEED TO DO SOMETHING
I THINK THIS IS A LOT STRONGER
TO ADDRESS THESE ISSUES BEFORE
THEY BECOME AND WE SHOULDN'T
HAVE TO WAIT FOR LITIGATION TO
DO SOMETHING MUCH MORE SERIOUS
AND DRAMATIC TO ADDRESS THE
PROBLEMS- WILL MOVE ONTO THE
NEXT ISSUE TO. WHICH IS THE- CDC
OURS MASTER PLAN ANNUAL REPORT
AND SUPPLEMENTAL REPORTING
LANGUAGE AND WE WILL START WITH
THE DEPARTMENT. A GOOD
AFTERNOON- MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF MY NAME IS DEAN
MORGAN I'M THE DIRECTOR FOR THE
FACILITY PLANNING CONSTRUCTION
AND MANAGEMENT DIISION WITHIN
CDCR. I'D LIKE TO START BY-
COMPLEMENTING VIA THE
CONSULTANTS- WORK IN PUTTING THE
AGENDA TOGETHER AGAIN-
SUMMARIZING THE MASTER PLAN
ANNUAL REPORT. OF THE
SUPPLEMENTAL REPORT- THE BEST
PLAN ANNUAL PORT WHICH IS KNOWN
BY THE ACRONYM EMPOWER ANNUALLY
PROVIDES INFORMATION ON CURRENT
PROJECTS RECENTLY COMPLETED
PROJECTS AND PROJECTS ARE EITHER
REQUESTING FUNDING FOR BUDGET
YEAR OR BUT YOUR PLUS ONE. OF
THEM ARE BECAUSE OF THIS FOCUS
HAS NOT HISTORICALLY- CONTAIN A
LOT OF INFORMATION THAT SHOWS
LONG TERM NEEDS- AT OUR AT OUR
PRISON SIT WITHIN OUR PRISON
SYSTEM. I IN RESPONSE TO
REQUESTS FROM THE LEGISLATURE
FOR REVIEW OF WHAT
INFRASTRUCTURE IMPROVEMENTS
MIGHT BE NEEDED OVER A LONGER
TERM. PERIOD OF TIME THAN WHAT
HAS BEEN SHOWN IN THE EMPOWER
SUPPLEMENTAL REPORTING LANGUAGE
OR S. R. L. WAS ADOPTED WITH THE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT. TO
DEVELOP A RESPONSE TO THE S. R.
L. C. D. C. R. REVIEWED SEVERAL
SOURCES OF DATA. TO IDENTIFY
PRISON INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS THAT
WERE SIGNIFICANT ENOUGH TO
WARRANT PRIORITIZATION OVER THAT
DURING THE NEXT TEN YEARS. THE
INCLUSION OF THIS INFORMATION
JOINT PROJECTS OVER THE NEXT TEN
YEARS HAS GREATLY ENHANCED THE
VALUE OF THE M. PAR AS A LONGER
TERM PLANNING DOCUMENT. WHEN
COMPARED TO THE IMPORTS THAT
HAVE BEEN RELEASED IN PRIOR
YEARS. THE REMAINING PORTION OF
THE S. R. L. RIGHT IT WAS
ADDRESSED IN THE NARRATIVE
SUPPLEMENT THAT WAS RELEASED
WITH THE- PART. OF PORTIONS OF
THE DISCUSSION THAT WAS
DISCUSSED AND THEY WERE INCLUDED
IN THE SUPPLEMENT. INCLUDED
WHETHER ANY OF THE PROJECTS
IDENTIFIED IN THE M. PARK WERE
SIGNIFICANT SCALE THAT OTHER
ALTERNATIVES SUCH AS
CONSOLIDATION OF PRISON SHOULD
BE CONSIDERED. HOW THE PROJECTS
IDENTIFIED MANPOWER SUPPORT A
LONG TERM DURABLE PORTFOLIO OF
FACILITIES FOR CDC ARE. AND
DESCRIBING THE STEPS TAKEN IN
PROJECT PLANNING AND
PRIORITIZATION TO MINIMIZE
INVESTMENTS IN PRISONS THAT MAY
BE CONSIDERED FOR FUTURE
CLOSURES. CHANGE YOUR
UNDERSTANDING OF THE S. R. L. I
WAS AT THE LEGISLATURE WAS
LOOKING FOR A DEEPER DIVE A
REGARDING LARGE PROJECTS THAT
WOULD BE NEEDED AT OUR
INSTITUTIONS IN THE FUTURE- THIS
SPECIFIC REQUEST WAS FOR
PROJECTS ESTIMATED TO COST. OVER
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS OR MORE-
AND THAT WE'RE LIKELY TO BE
NEEDED OVER THE NEXT TEN YEARS.
BUT ALL STATES ARE ALSO
REQUESTED- CDCR LOOK AT WHETHER
THE PROJECTS NEEDED NEXT TEN
YEARS DROVE THE NEED FOR ANY
PRISON CONSOLIDATIONS. THE
INFORMATION THAT WE SUBMITTED-
BOTH IN THE M. R. AND THEN THE
S. R. L. IDENTIFIES THE
ANTICIPATED PROJECT NEEDS THAT
ARE ACTIVE INSTITUTIONS. AND
FOUND THAT THOSE IDENTIFY NEEDS
DID NOT DRIVE A FURTHER NEED TO
CONSIDER CONSOLIDATION OF
PRISONS SO BASED ON CDC OURS
INTERPRETATION OF THE S. R. L.
REQUEST. WE BELIEVE C. SARS
REPORT IT IS RESPONSIVE TO THE
S. R. L. THE M. CAR IN THE US
ARE OLD RESPONSE I WAS PROVIDED
REGARDING FUTURE PROJECT NEEDS
IS INTENDED PRIMARILY TO BE A
PLANNING DOCUMENT FOR WHAT
PROJECTS. C. C. R. MACY IN THE
FUTURE. IT DOES NOT REPRESENT
REPRESENT OUR CURRENT BUDGET
REQUEST AND THUS MUCH OF THE
INFORMATION IN THE OF THE
REGARDING THE FUTURE PROJECTS IS
CONCEPTUAL IN NATURE. IT'S
IMPORTANT NOTE THAT THE M. CAR
AND THE S. R. O. RESPONSE IS NOT
INTENDED BY CDCR TO PROVIDE
JUSTIFICATIONS- TO THE SENATE
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE FOR THE
PROJECTS THAT ARE BEFORE THE
SUBCOMMITTEE SEEKING FUNDING IN
THE TWENTY. TWENTY TWO BUDGET
ACT. THE DETAILED INFORMATION
REGARDING THE NEEDS ADDRESSED BY
EACH PROJECT THAT WE ARE SEEKING
FUNDING FOR- THE ALTERNATIVES
CONSIDERED FOR THOSE PROJECTS.
AND HELP PROJECTS FIT WITH A
DURABLE PORTFOLIO FACILITIES. IS
PROVIDED IN THE DOCUMENTS THAT
ACCOMPANIED THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET IN JANUARY. THE PROJECTS
THAT WILL BE DISCUSSED IN THE
FOLLOWING TWO ITEMS BUT TODAY
ARE REQUESTED BY CDC R. AS THE
HIGHEST PRIORITIES FACING CDC
ARE TODAY TO SUPPORT THE
PROVISION OF KEY PROGRAMS SUCH
AS MENTAL HEALTH CARE MEDICAL
CARE SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER
TREATMENT. OPTION SYSTEM WITH
CDCR RESPONSIBILITIES AND-
ADDRESS KEY INFRASTRUCTURE SUCH
AS WATER AIR COOLING AND
SECURITY RADIUS. SO WITH THAT I
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BRIEFLY PRESENT ON THIS ITEM
TODAY AS AN INFORMATIONAL ITEM
AND I'LL BE AVAILABLE TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS AFTER THE- OTHER
PANELS THAT SPOKE. THANK YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU MR BOARD- YOUR
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WOULD YOU
LIKE TO MAKE ANY COMMENTS. YES
GOOD AFTERNOON PUBLISHED WED AND
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE OKAY I'M
PART OF THIS YEAR PROVIDES MORE
INFORMATION THAN IT HAS IN
PREVIOUS. SECOND FOR STRUCTURE
PROJECTS AT CDC ARE AS WELL AS
POTENTIAL FUTURE PROJECTS OVER
THE NEXT TEN YEARS. AND WE WOULD
BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY FURTHER
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE. THANK
YOU- L. A. O. IS THAT YOU MISS
CAITLYN. YES THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR ONE YOUNG AGAIN WITHOUT
LEO- THE REPORT THAT CDC ARE
SUBMITTED TO THE LEGISLATURE
RECENTLY- THAT IS THE SUBJECT OF
THIS INFORMATIONAL ITEMS. DIAL
IS IN RESPONSE TO SUPPLEMENTAL
REPORTING LANGUAGE THAT WAS
ADOPTED BY THE LEGISLATURE WITH
THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUDGET
PACKAGE- AND- AMONG OTHER
REQUIREMENTS THAT SUPPLEMENTAL
REPORTING LANGUAGE DIRECTED CDCR
TO. SEEK OPPORTUNITIES TO
CONSOLIDATE PRESENTS TO ACHIEVE
EFFICIENCIES AND TO DESCRIBE HOW
THE IDENTIFIED PROJECTS WHICH
SUPPORT A LONG TERM DURABLE
PORTFOLIO OF FACILITIES TO MEET
THE DEPARTMENT'S MISSION AND THE
STATE'S LONG TERM NEED FOR
PRISON CAPACITY. AND WE FIND
THAT THE REPORT ISN'T FULLY
RESPONSIVE TO THESE TO THESE
DIRECTIONS- FOR TWO MAIN REASONS
THE FIRST ISTHAT IT DOES NOT-
ACCOUNT FOR THE SIGNIFICANT
PROJECTED DECLINE IN THE PRISON
POPULATION AND- SUBSEQUENTLY THE
NEED FOR PRISON CAPACITY TO
HOUSE THAT POPULATION- IN OTHER
WORDS THE REPORT ASSUMES THAT
ALL FACILITIES THAT ARE
OPERATING TODAY WILL. CONTINUE
TO BE OPERATED TEN YEARS FROM
NOW- DESPITE THE PROJECTED
POPULATION DECLINE AND THE
LEGISLATURE'S DIRECTION TO SEEK
OPPORTUNITIES TO CONSOLIDATE
PRESENTS DECEIVED ACHIEVE
EFFICIENCIES- SECOND THE WE
UNDERSTAND BASED ON
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION THAT IT DIDN'T DO
A SYSTEMATIC REVIEW OF. THE
INMATE REHABILITATION AND HEALTH
CARE NEEDS AS IT IDENTIFIED
PROJECTS SO WHILE THERE ARE SOME
THERE ARE A FEW PROJECTS IN THE
TEN YEAR- LIST OF PROJECTS THAT
DO ADDRESSED REHABILITATION AND
HEALTH CARE NEEDS. IT DOESN'T
APPEAR THAT THAT SAY- REFLECTS
REFLECTIVE OF A COMPREHENSIVE
ANALYSIS OF PROJECTED NEED AND
THOSE- IN THOSE AREAS- AND THEN
WHILE THE S. R. L. DID NOT
DIRECTLY REQUIRE CDCR TO
CONSIDER THE INTERSECTION
BETWEEN- COVER NINETEEN OR OTHER
FUTURE POTENTIALLY- AIRBORNE
DISEASES- SIXTY EIGHT WE KNOW
THAT THE PLAN DOES NOT CONSIDER-
THAT ISSUE THAT PUBLIC HEALTH
CONCERNS- AND- LOCAL EXPERTS
HAVE TESTIFIED IN COURT THAT THE
ARCHITECTURE IN PARTICULAR AT
SAN QUENTIN HAS BEEN
PARTICULARLY PROBLEMATIC DURING
KOBE AND- AND- OTHER PRISONS.
WELL THEY HAVEN'T BEEN
SCRUTINIZED AS CLOSELY AS SAN
QUENTIN COULD HAVE SIMILAR
CONCERNS- AND SO THE MAIN POINT
HERE THE MAIN TAKEAWAY WHETHER
WHETHER OR NOT ONE VIEWS A
SUPPORT TO BE RESPONSIVE TO
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTION- IT DOES
SEEM THAT THESE LIMITATIONS I'VE
DESCRIBED TO. INDICATE THAT THE
LIST OF PROJECTS THAT CDCR HAS
INCLUDED IN THE REPORT ON THE
ONE HAND MAY INCLUDE PROJECTS
THAT WON'T ALTER THAT ULTIMATELY
BE NEEDED BECAUSE- THOSE
PARTICULAR FACILITIES MAY
ULTIMATELY BE CLOSED DUE TO
DECLINE IN THE NEED FOR PRISON
CAPACITY- ON THE OTHER HAND THE
REPORT LIKELY MISSES CERTAIN
PROJECTS THAT WILL BE NEEDED-
GIVEN THAT IT DIDN'T- GET OUT
THE DEPARTMENT DIDN'T CONDUCT A
SYSTEMATIC EVALUATION OF.
CERTAIN ISSUES THAT HAVE KEEN
ACCESS WITH FACILITIES. I'M
AVAILABLE FOR QUESTIONS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISS O'NEILL-
COLLEAGUE SARAH COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS SENATOR NEWMAN. THANK
YOU AND SHERRY I ACTUALLY
REMEMBER WELL A CONVERSATION
LAST YEAR THANK YOU- I'M SURE
YOU'LL GET TO THIS BRIDGE AND
CLOSURES WHAT I WANT I WANT TO
STEP ON NO NO NO QUESTION. BUT
THE NOTES NOTE THAT HERE WE HAVE
THIS KIND OF ISSUE CATCH TWENTY
TWO WHERE THE ADMINISTRATION
SAID. SAYS SOMETHING VERY GOOD
YOU KNOW THE CLOSURES ARE POINT
TIME DECISION EVEN THOUGH- LET
YOU KNOW IN THE LARGER CONTEXT
WE KNOW THAT WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
TO. GO OUT WITH THAT THERE ARE
PLANS TO CONSOLIDATE OR CLOSE
CERTAIN FACILITIES SO I GUESS MY
QUESTION FOR. THE BELLAGIO HOW
DO WE SQUARE. THIS CIRCLE- IT
BECAUSE THIS IS. A CANISTERS TO
FEEL LIKE KICKING THE CAN. ARE
YOU ASKING FOR HOW DO YOU AVOID
APPROVING. SORT OF A PLAN FOR
HOW TO AVOID APPROVING EDS
PROJECTS YES AND HOW DO WE GET
TO SOMETHING A LITTLE MORE- YOU
KNOW WELL PRESCRIBES SO THAT
WE'RE NOT HAVING THE SAME
CONVERSATION NEXT YEAR- WELL WE
HAVE. RECOMMENDED IN THE PAST
THAT THE LEGISLATURE. WRITTEN
DIRECTED DEPARTMENT TO REQUIRE
TO REPORT A LIST OF PRISONS THAT
IT VIEWS AS- STRONG CANDIDATES
FOR CLOSURE- AND WE'VE SUGGESTED
CERTAIN CRITERIA THAT THE
LEGISLATURE COULD CONSIDER IN.
DIRECTING THE DEPARTMENT TO
REPORT THAT LAST A LITTLE BLOOD
SUGAR COULD OF COURSE- DEVELOP
ITS OWN CRITERIA- DOT HAS NOT
RESULTED IN- THE MINISTRATION.
PROVIDING PRISONS OR OR EVEN
INDICATING- SORT OF A STRATEGY
WITH RESPECT TO. WHETHER IT
INTENDS TO CLOSE PRISONS VERSES
CLOSE PORTIONS OF PRISONS AS IT
HAS IT HAS IT DONE BOTH IN
RECENT YEARS- ANOTHER OPTION OF
THE LEGISLATURE COULD PURSUE
COULD BE TO- IDENTIFY PRISONS
THAT IT THINKS. ARE STRONG GET
CANDIDATES FOR CLOSURE AND THEN
SIMPLY NOT APPROVED-
SIGNIFICANT- YOU KNOW- OR LONG
TERM. INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENTS
AT THOSE PRESENTS- WE HAVE
IDENTIFIED PRISON AT WHICH I.
TEST ON LAST YEAR WHICH WERE
SEEN CLINTON- CALIFORNIA
INSTITUTION FOR MEN- CALIFORNIA.
MEN'S COLONY- CORRECTIONAL
TRAINING FACILITY- AND
CALIFORNIA REHABILITATION CENTER
AS STRONG CANDIDATES FOR CLOSURE
BASED ON THEIR- PRIMARILY THEIR
INFRASTRUCTURE THERE WHAT WAS
THAT PRIOR TO THIS REPORT- VERY
SIGNIFICANT INFRASTRUCTURE
CURRENT NEEDS ADDS ESTIMATED BY-
AN EXTERNAL CONSULTING FIRM
KITCHELL- AS WELL AS THEIR
OPERATIONAL COSTS PER INMATE-
CDCR DOESN'T THINK BASED ON THIS
REPORT THAT THE STATE WILL
ULTIMATELY NEED TO INVEST MAKE
INVESTMENTS IN THE
INFRASTRUCTURE- ON THE SCALE
THAT CONTROL RECOMMENDED. BUT
NEVERTHELESS THESE FACILITIES DO
SEEM TO HAVE ON BALANCE SOME
PRETTY SIGNIFICANT
INFRASTRUCTURE- ISSUES. SO
THAT'S ANOTHER APPROACH THE
LOGISTIC LEGISLATURE COULD
CONSIDER. AM I ANSWERING YOUR
QUESTION ABSOLUTELY ABSOLUTELY
YOU ARE APPRECIATED SODA DIED
LOVE TO WE COULD HEAR FROM MR
BOARD AS WELL- YOU KNOW IF YOU
ACCEPT GENERALLY THE YOU KNOW
THE PREMISE OF THE B. ELLIE OWES
ASSESSMENT AND ANALYSIS HOW HOW
SHOULD WE THE LEGISLATURE BE
THINKING SMARTLY ABOUT THIS.
WE'LL TAKE INTO ACCOUNT SOME OF
THE CHALLENGES YOU FACE YOU MAKE
THESE KINDS OF DECISIONS ARE
PROJECTIONS. THANK YOU SENATOR
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO RESPOND.
NUMBER OF OTHER THINGS TO TRY TO
IMPACT THERE BUT I THINK THAT-
THEY WORK THE REPORT IS
DISCUSSING A LOT OF THE
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS AT THESE
PRISONS BUT I THINK CDC OURS-
ANOTHER KEY COMPONENT IS AT C.
C. R. DOES NOT FEEL THAT THE
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS ARE THE
DRIVER OF ANY FUTURE PRISON
CLOSURE DECISIONS- THE CDCR
NEEDS TO LOOK AT THE MISSION OF
PRISONS. HERE'S A LOOK AT THE
POPULATION THAT WE'RE SERVING
OUR OBLIGATIONS REGARDING MENTAL
HEALTH MENTAL MEDICAL HEALTHCARE
AND ALL OTHER THOSE OTHER
CONSIDERATIONS- THE ABILITY TO
STAFF PRISONS IT'S MUCH MORE
OPERATIONAL CONSIDERATION FOR
THAT RATHER THAN SOMETHING THAT
WOULD BE DRIVEN BY A PRIMARILY
INFRASTRUCTURE FOCUSED REPORT
REPORT- AND I WOULD JUST SAY
IT'S NOT- THAT NOT NECESSARILY
UNDER MY PURVIEW BUT I THINK
THAT APARTMENT HAS. TESTIFIED
AND IN MAY THE POSITIONS IN THE
PAST THAT IT HAS- IT IT DOES NOT
AGREE WITH THE CONCEPT OF
PUTTING OUT A LIST OF PRISONS TO
CLOSE- OR THAT COULD BE
CONSIDERED FOR CLOSURE- DUE TO
WHAT IT CONSIDERS TO BE
DETRIMENTAL EFFECTS THAT WOULD
OCCUR AT THOSE PRISONS-
REGARDING STAFFING AND OTHER
CONSIDERATIONS. SO I GUESS WHAT
I WANT TO GO BACK TO IS LANGUAGE
THAT WE INCLUDED IN OUR REPORT
THAT DISCUSSES HOW THE PROJECTS
THAT ARE PUT FORWARD ESPECIALLY
PROJECTS THAT ARE INCLUDED IN
THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET MARK ARE
CAREFULLY VETTED THROUGH A
NUMBER OF DIFFERENT LAYERS OF-
L. C. D. C. R. C. C. H. C. S.
WITHIN THE ADMINISTRATION- IN A
CAREFULLY WEIGHS THE NEED FOR
THE PROJECTS THAT ARE INCLUDED.
FOR IN THE FUNDING REQUESTS
AGAINST THE RISK THAT IT COULD
BE IMPACTED BY FUTURE PRISON
CLOSURES OTHER PROJECTS THAT ARE
IN FRONT OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE
THAT'LL. BE DISCUSSED- NEXT
ITEMS. US NEEDS PRESENT WHERE WE
- HAVE. A HIGH NUMBERS OF HIGH
RISK MEDICAL CARE. YOU KNOW IN
THE IN THE INCARCERATED
POPULATION REQUIRES A HIGH RISK
MEDICAL CARE OF THEIR MEMBERS
ARE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
DELIVERY SYSTEM- AND WE FEEL
THAT THESE ARE NAMES THAT ARE
IMPORTANT TO ADDRESS NOW- EVEN
IN LIGHT OF THE FACT THAT THERE
WILL BE IN THE FUTURE A
POTENTIAL ADDITIONAL DECISIONS
MADE REGARDING CULTURES. AND I
DO I DO APPRECIATE THAT HELP
TURN IT BACK TO YOU- MADAM CHAIR
AGAIN YOU KNOW LIKE I GUESS THE
QUESTION THAT WE NEED TO WRESTLE
WITH US IN LEGISLATURES YOU KNOW
HOW HOW CAN WE OR CAN WE AVOID
MAKING CAN A CAPITAL EXPENDITURE
INFRASTRUCTURE PRESENTS AND FOR
FACILITIES THAT. WILL YOU KNOW
WILL BE THERE FOR WHICH THAT TO
USE ONE YOU KNOW FOR FIVE YEARS-
STRETCH IN A TIME WHERE WE DO
NOT ENJOY WHEN I LIKE ENJOY THE
KIND OF SURPLUSES THAT WE DO
TODAY SIR. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR. I WILL GO WITH A
FURTHER TO SAY THAT I'M
DISAPPOINTED. IN THE CD SARS
RESPONSE- THIS IS A-
LEGISLATURE'S BEEN ASKING FOR
THE INFORMATION. VERY CLEAR THAT
WE EXPECTED IN THE SUPPLEMENTAL
REPORTING LANGUAGE- AND HOW DO
WE MAKE. MEANINGFUL MAKE A
MEANINGFUL EVALUATION AND
DISCUSS FOR EXAMPLE THE NEXT
ISSUE CAPITAL OUTLAY PROJECTS
WITHOUT THE BENEFIT THAT THE-
CONVERSATION IN THE CONTEXT OF A
LONG TERM STRATEGY AND HERE WE
ARE- A YEAR LATER. WOULD
FUNDAMENTALLY THE SAME
QUESTIONS- THIS IS DEJA VU- SO
SIMILAR TO THE DISCUSSION THAT
WE HAD THE SAME TIME. HIS LAST
YEAR IN THE SUBCOMMITTEE- ON
WE'RE NOT ASKING FOR A LIST OF
PRISONS TO BE CLOSED. WE ARE
ASKING TO HAVE A PLAN A
STRATEGY- SO THAT WE CAN FILL
OUR RESPONSIBILITY BECAUSE WE DO
HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY. NOT ONLY
TO THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
INCARCERATED- MAKE SURE THAT
THEY HAVE SAFE CONDITIONS BUT
ALSO TO THE INVESTMENTS OF THE-
THE TAX DOLLARS. THAT WE MANAGE-
THE POPULATION OF THE PRISON
SYSTEM IS CHANGING BUT YOU KNOW
WHAT THOSE TRENDS ARE- WE NEED
TO LOOK AT THOSE AND MAKE
INFORMED DECISIONS- ARE YOU YOU
MAKE PROJECTIONS ABOUT THE SIZE
FOR EXAMPLE AND OF. CERTAIN
GROUPS THE AGE DISTRIBUTION THE
KINDS OF HEALTH NEEDS- THERE'S
SO MANY OF THESE ISSUES THAT.
FRANKLY MANY ALL DEPARTMENTS
ACROSS OUR OUR STATE AND
GOVERNMENT ARE ASKED TO MAKE
PLANS. AND- FROM WHAT I CAN SEE
THE YOU'RE ONE OF THE ONLY ONES
THAT THE ONLY ONE THAT I'VE SEEN
THAT DOESN'T WANT TO PROVIDE
THAT VISION ON THE PLAN TO US.
MAKES IT VERY VERY DIFFICULT FOR
US WELL WE'RE IN THIS REACTIVE
STRATEGY- TO HAVE THEN HAVE TO
MAKE DECISIONS WHICH WE KNOW
IMPORTANT DECISIONS ON THINGS
LIKE THE CAPITAL OUTLAY- YOU
KNOW. THE ISSUE DOES COME UP OF
COURSE A BIG ISSUE IS. WHAT WHAT
ABOUT THESE FACILITIES ARE ANY
BUMPER WHAT REASONS MIGHT BE
BECAUSE IT- HOT FOR
CONSOLIDATION- WE KNOW THAT THE
OUR PRISON POPULATION IS
SIGNIFICANTLY LOWER- WHERE DOES
THAT FIT INTO THIS AND WHAT ARE
WE WHAT ARE YOUR PLANS TO DO TO
HANDLE THAT BECAUSE IT WILL BE
LESS- THERE'S ENVIRONMENTAL
ISSUES THAT ARE NOW. IN THE
PRISONS- AND OF COURSE WE FIND
OUT ABOUT OUR ABILITY OR
INABILITY TO DEAL WITH SOMETHING
LIKE THE CORPORATE NINETEEN-
THIS HAS THESE ISSUES HAVE BEEN
RAISED FOR MANY YEARS BY
ADVOCATES OF- AND NOW WE'VE SEEN
OVER AND OVER AGAIN HOW
IMPACTFUL THEY ARE SUPER THE
PRISON PRISON IMPRISONED MEN AND
WOMEN SO. ARE I FOR ONE NOT JUST
GOING TO SAY THAT'S FINE LET'S
LET'S SEE WHAT YOU DO NEXT YEAR
I DON'T THINK THAT'S ACCEPTABLE-
SO WE'LL- SEE WHAT WE SEE- HOW
WE DEAL WITH THAT. IN THIS
BUDGET. SO WE MOVE ON NOW TO THE
NEXT ISSUE ISSUE THREE CAPITAL
OUTLAY PROPOSALS. C. A. R. IS
THAT MR LEAVE YES THANK YOU-
CHRIS LEAF- DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
FACILITIES PLANNING AND
CONSTRUCTION MANAGEMENT AT C. D.
C. R. I'M SORRY I HAD A- TROUBLE
WITH MY- BUTTON- AND DECIDE ON
THEIR TOTAL OF. FOURTEEN CAPITAL
OUTLAY REQUESTS FOR CDC ARE-
THESE INCLUDE TWO NEW PROJECTS
FIVE CONTINUING PROJECTS- A FIVE
YEAR PREPARATIONS AND TO FIND
SHIPS. OKAY OKAY QUICK OVERVIEW
OF THE NEW AND CONTINUING
PROJECT. TWO NEW PROJECTS ARE
BOTH AT CALIFORNIA STATE PRISON
CORCORAN. THE FIRST IS THREE
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY ONE THOUSAND
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND FOR THE
JUST SIGNED UP TO INDIVIDUAL
EXERCISE YARDS TO PROVIDE
MAXIMUM CUSTODY INMATES
RECEIVING MENTAL HEALTHCRISIS
CARE AT THE CORRECTIONAL
TREATMENT CENTER FOR PARTICIPATE
IN OUT OF SELL RECREATIONAL
THERAPY CONSISTENT WITH OUR
TREATMENT PLANT. THE SECOND NEW
PROJECTS THAT ARE CREATING GAMES
EIGHT HUNDRED AND SIX THOUSAND
GENERAL FUND FOR THE INITIAL
STAGE OF DESIGN FOR A NEW RADIO
TOWER AND EQUIPMENT FAULT. TO
SUPPORT RADIO COMMUNICATIONS
BOTH CORCORAN AND CALIFORNIA
SUBSTANCE ABUSE TREATMENT
FACILITY. FIVE CONTINUING
PROJECTS INCLUDE FOUR PROJECTS
MOVING INTO CONSTRUCTION AND ONE
MOVING INTO THE FINAL STAGE
DESIGN. OUR FIRST IS UP THREE
POINTS- THREE FIVE MILLION
GENERAL FUND FOR THE
CONSTRUCTION OF A MEDICAL
MEDICATION PREPARATION ROOM AT
CALIFORNIA STATE PRISON LOS
ANGELES COUNTY UNIT T. FIVE TO
SUIT THE SERVER ENHANCED
OUTPATIENT OUTPATIENTS AND THE
ADMINISTRATIVE SEGREGATION. NEXT
IS TWO MILLION GENERAL FUND TO
CONSTRUCT TEN INDIVIDUAL
EXERCISE YARDS CALIFORNIA HEALTH
CARE FACILITY- THESE EXERCISE
YARDS WILL ALLOW MASK MAXIMUM
CLASSIFICATIONS RECEIVING
INPATIENT MENTAL HEALTH CARE.
THIS BAND AND OUT OF CELL
RECREATION THERAPY CONSISTENT
WITH EXTRA ITEMS. NEXT IS
THIRTEEN POINT FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS FOR CONSTRUCTION OF A
PROJECT TO PROVIDE AIR COOLING
OUT WITH REQUIRED FIRE LIFE
SAFETY IMPROVEMENTS AND
REHABILITATIVE TREATMENT
EDUCATION AND OFFICE SPACE
WITHIN THE CALIFORNIA SUBSTANCE
TREATMENT FACILITY F. AND G.
HOUSING UNITS. THIS PROJECT WILL
PROVIDE INDOOR TEMPERATURES
SUITABLE FOR INCARCERATED
INDIVIDUALS TO RECEIVE TREATMENT
AND EDUCATION. THANKS TO THE
FOURTEEN POINT FOUR MILLION
GENERAL FUNDS FOR CONSTRUCTION
OF THE COGNITIVE BEHAVIORAL
TREATMENT CLASSROOMS A
CALIFORNIA STATE PRISON
SACRAMENTO. EGYPT WILL PROVIDE
SPACE TO PROVIDE THE COGNITIVE
BEHAVIORAL INTERVENTION PROGRAM
AT- ABSTRACT. THE LAST PROJECT
HIGHLIGHT IS ONE POINT ONE
BILLION DOLLARS JOURNAL FUNDS
FOR THE COMPLETION OF DESIGN OF
NEW GLOBAL WATER WELLS AT
CHUCKWALLA VALLEY STATE PRISON
ARE THESE WELLS WILL PROVIDE.
GLOBAL WATER TO BOTH CHUCKWALLA
VALLEY STATE PRISON AND ARMED
WITH STICKERS. AND THANK YOU YOU
TOO THANK- OKAY THANK YOU MISTER
LEAVE- DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
WOULD YOU LIKE TO COMMENT. YES
PUBLISHED WHY DIDN'T APARTMENT
OF FINANCE ADMINISTRATION
CONTINUES TO SUPPORT THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET WHICH INCLUDES
THREE HUNDRED AND ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION NEW GENERAL FUND
AUTHORITY. AND EIGHT POINT SEVEN
MILLION GENERAL SUNDRY
APPROPRIATION AUTHORITY FOR THE
FIFTEEN CAPITAL OUTLAY PROJECTS
FOURTEEN OF WHICH ARE INCLUDED
IN THE SH THIS ISSUE ONE OF
WHICH IS IN THE NEXT SURE. AND
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY FURTHER
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- LA- PLEASE. YOU
DON'T RAISE CONCERNS ON ANY OF
THESE PROPOSALS SPECIFICALLY
OKAY THANK YOU MR NAIL. AND
COLLEAGUES ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. OKAY I HAVE- TO- I
REMEMBER THIS WAS DISCUSSED LAST
YEAR ABOUT THE- WATER AT VALLEY
STATE PRISON IN CHOWCHILLA AND-
I UNDERSTAND THIS PROJECT IS
STILL DELAYED- SO MAYBE YOU
COULD TALK ABOUT THAT AND ALSO
WHAT IS BEING DONE TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEIR SAFETY DRINKING WATER
IN THE MEANTIME- SO I THINK
YOU'RE REFERRING TO THE- ARSENIC
IN MAGGIE MAGGIE NEEDS.
TREATMENT FACILITY AT PALLISTER
STATE PRISON YES- YOU'RE CORRECT
THAT THE DESIGN OF THAT PROJECT
HAS BEEN. DELAYED THERE WERE
SOME CHANGES IN THE WATER SUPPLY
THAT NEEDED FURTHER ANALYSIS-
THAT- REQUIRED- UNTIL LATE IN
THE DESIGN. WE ANTICIPATE THAT
OUR PROJECTS- WILL BE BACK IN
FRONT OF YOU IN A FUTURE BUDGET
CYCLE- IN IN THE MEANTIME- THE-
INSTITUTION CONTINUES TO BLAND
WATER FROM THE VARIOUS SOURCES-
TO- PROVIDE- SAFE DRINKING WATER
TO THE POPULATION. OF THOSE
INSTITUTIONS. AND I'M SORRY THE
SECOND WAS ABOUT. IT WAS ABOUT
THEM WHAT DO YOU DO IN THE
MEANWHILE TO PROVIDE SAFE
DRINKING OUTSIDE I TOOK OVER
THAT YEAH- AND THEN I HAVE OF
THE OTHER QUESTION I HAVE IS- WE
HAVE BEEN HEARING- ABOUT THE
CONCERNS ABOUT THE BILL ABILITY
OF VISITATION SPACES AND-
PROGRAMMING SPACIOUS SPACES OF.
COULD YOU TALK ABOUT THAT. WE
HAVE KNOWN I MEAN AS YOU KNOW WE
HAVE NO PROPOSALS FOR THOSE
KINDS OF SPACES- AND NOW AS FAR
AS A CAPITAL REQUEST GOES SO I'M
NOT AWARE- ANY SPECIFICS TO- ADD
TO THE CONVERSATION AT THIS
POINT. OKAY WELL WE'LL WE'LL GET
MORE SPECIFIC BUT I GUESS THE
QUESTION IS AS YOU'RE DOING AS
YOU TO KENTUCKY INTO ACCOUNT.
THESE THESE PROPOSALS ARE ARE
YOU INCLUDING THE NEED FOR SPACE
FOR PROGRAMMING ON THE NEED FOR
SPACE FOR VISITATION. YES SIR
CERTAINLY THEIR THEIR NUMBER OF
DRIVERS FOR- INFRASTRUCTURE AND
CAPITAL NEEDS AT AT OUR PRISONS-
WE DO HAVE- PROPOSALS FOR
REHABILITATIVE SPACE THE-
SACRAMENTO- CSP SACRAMENTO-
CLASSROOM SPACES AN EXAMPLE-
AND- WE CERTAINLY ARE SENSITIVE
TO THE- IMPORTANCE OF-
VISITATION. AND PROGRAMMING
SPACE AND THE PERSON'S. OKAY THE
MORE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS-
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OUT ARE YOU
GOING TO CONTINUE TO DO- ISSUE
NUMBER FOUR MR LEAVE. I WILL
START OUT ON ISSUE NUMBER FOUR
AND THEN THE HAND OFF TO MY-
COLLEAGUES- SO THE FIRST ISSUE
IS THAT THE TEST TEAMS- CAPITAL
OUTLAY PROPOSAL THAT MYSTERIOUS
SPRAYED AND- ALLUDED TO. WHICH
IS NE MILLION DOLLARS TO FIND
FOR FANS PLANNING PURPOSES. FOR
FUTURE CAPITAL OUTLAY PROJECTS-
THE SCOND IS A SEVENTY THREE
MILLION DOLLAR ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND REQUEST. FOR PROOF
REPLACEMENTS AT THE CALIFORNIA
INSTITUTION FOR MEN AND THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL FACILITY.
THAT'S A STARTING AS IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN THE LEGISLATURE HAS
PROVIDED THREE HUNDRED AND
THIRTEEN MILLION OF SPECIAL CARE
FUNDING FOR ROOF REPLACEMENTS AT
ELEVEN PERSONS. AND REPLACING
GROUPS EXTEND THE USEFUL LIFE OF
HER PRISONER CONSTRUCTION- AND
HELP MAINTAIN CONTINUITY OF
PROGRAMS WITHIN PRISONS- THAT
LASTS A REQUEST THAT I WILL
ADDRESS. IS ONE POINT ONE
MILLION DOLLARS OF REIMBURSEMENT
AUTHORITY AND THIRTEEN OFFICE
TECHNICIAN POSITIONS- TO PROVIDE
SUPPORT TO OUR INMATE WORK LABOR
PROGRAM WHICH USES INMATE AND
TRADE LABOR TO CONSTRUCT BOTH
CAPITAL OUTLAY AND SPECIAL
REPAIR FUNDED PROJECTS THAT ARE
INSTITUTIONS. ROGER CONSTRUCTED
BY THE OTHER REAL PROGRAM HAVE
INCREASED IN COMPLEXITY AND
THESE COMPLEX PROJECTS HAVE MANY
ADMINISTRATIVE REQUIREMENTS THAT
ARE CURRENTLY HANDLED BY
CONSTRUCTION SUPERVISORS- THE
OFFICE TECHNICIANS IN THIS
PROPOSAL WILL RELIEVE THE
CONSTRUCTION SUPERVISORS OF
THESE ADMINISTRATIVE DUTIES.
ALLOWING THEM TO FOCUS ON THE
SUPERVISION OF CONSTRUCTION IT'S
- WITHOUT I'M HAND IT OVER TO.
MR CLINTON. THAT AFTERNOON ABOUT
VERSACE'S MODEL MCLEAN DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OFFICE OF THE SCHOOL
SERVICES PURSEEASIER I'M
COVERING THE UTILITIES AND WASTE
REMOVAL ITEM THIS REQUEST
ESTABLISHES A UPDATED FUNDING
METHODOLOGY FOR UTILITIES AND
WASTE REMOVAL CREDITORS
PREVIOUSLY UTILITIES AT
REASONABLE COSTS FOR BUDGET
AUTECHRE INNATE BASIS WHICH HAS
LESS THAN APARTMENT UNDERFUNDED
BECAUSE THIS METHODOLOGY DOES
NOT ACCOUNT FOR TRUE COST
DRIVERS OF THESE EXPENDITURES.
ADJUSTING THE FUNNY METHODOLOGY
WILL DISCUSS HIS ASSOCIATE THE
FINDING FROM A POPULATION
CHANGES AND USES A THREE YEAR
AVERAGE ACTUAL EXPENDITURES AS
THE NEW BABY ADDITIONALLY THIS
REQUEST WELL ESTABLISHED A
MECHANISM TO ADJUST THE FUNDING
UP OR DOWN. BASED ON
CALIFORNIA'S TPI. WITH THAT I
WILL TRY IT OVER TO GAVE YOU CAN
LAST. THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I'M RON DAVIS
ASSOCIATE DIRECTOR DIVISION OF
ADULT INSTITUTIONS ZERO REQUEST
ONE POINT FIVE MILLION FOR A
CONSULTING CONTRACT TO EVALUATE
THE CONDEMNED HOUSING RECREATION
AND SPORTS SPACES AT SAN QUENTIN
FOR USED POST CONDEMNED. AS
CONSULT WILL PROVIDE IDEAS HOW
TO USE THIS EXISTING SPACE- ARE
HOW THIS EXISTING SPACE CAN BE
USED TO CREATE A POSITIVE
HEALING ENVIRONMENT THAT
PROVIDES INCREASED
REHABILITATIVE EDUCATIONAL AND
HEALTHCARE OPPORTUNITIES AT SAC
QUITE THANK YOU FOR TAKING YOUR
TIME AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU HAVE ON THIS
MATTER. OKAY. DEPARTMENT FINANCE
WOULD YOU LIKE TO COMMENT. JUST
TO REITERATE THE
ADMINISTRATION'S SUPPORT FOR THE
CAPITAL OUTLAY PROPOSALS
INCLUDING THE ONE OUTLINED IN
THIS ISSUE. OKAY M. L. A. O. I'M
WE DON'T RAISE CONCERNS ON ANY
OF THESE PROPOSALS EXCEPT FOR
THE REQUEST FOR ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION TO CONTRACT WITH A
CONSULTANT TO RE ENVISION
CONDEMNED HOUSING AT SAN QUENTIN
I'M NOT IS BECAUSE THE
ARCHITECTURE OF CERTAIN HOUSING
FACILITIES AT ST CLINTON HAVE
BEEN PARTICULARLY PROBLEMATIC
DURING THE PANDEMIC- AND THAT
INCLUDES THE FACILITIES THAT ARE
THE SUBJECT OF THIS PROPOSAL AND
THEY'VE BEEN PARTICULARLY
PROBLEMATIC PRIMARILY BECAUSE
THEY CONSIST OF FIVE TIERS OF
CELLS- STACKED ON TOP OF EACH
OTHER WITH OPEN BAR DOORS
ALLOWING AIR TO FLOW BETWEEN
NEIGHBORING CELLS AS WELL AS-
FROM TOP TO BOTTOM. AND THERE IS
VERY LITTLE OUTSIDE ERR INTAKE
AS MANY OF THE WINDOWS WE
UNDERSTAND- WELL THE CHILD AND-
THE AIR INSIDE THE FACILITY IS
ESSENTIALLY CIRCULATED BY LARGE.
INDUSTRIAL FANS- AND SO WELL
CDCR HASN'T DEFINED THE SCOPE OF
THE CONSULTANTS OF WHAT THE
CONSULTANT WOULD DO IF APPROVED-
WE UNDERSTAND BASED ON
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT THAT IT DOES NOT PLAN
TO. REQUIRE THE CONSULTANT TO
CONSIDER- THE ABOVE ARE THE
PUBLIC HEALTH CONCERNS THAT I.
DESCRIBED AND WE ARE CONCERNED
THAT TO DATE TO THE EXTENT CDC
ARE LATER MODIFIED THE FACILITY
TO ADDRESS THESE CONCERNS I SAID
JUST BY ADDING SOME KIND OF
THAT- SYSTEM FOR. EXCHANGING THE
AIR I'M- MORE FREQUENTLY. IT
COULD REQUIRE THE DEPARTMENT TO
UNDO OR DESTROY WHATEVER
MODIFICATIONS RESULTS FROM THIS
CONSULTANTS- RECOMMENDATIONS.
AND SO WE RECOMMEND THAT THE
LEGISLATURE DIRECTED DEPARTMENT
TO REPORT AT BUDGET HEARINGS ON-
THAT **** DAY- DEFINE SCOPE OF
THE PROPOSED CONSULTANTS WORK.
THE RATIONALE FOR NOT HAVING THE
CONSULTANT CONSIDER THE PUBLIC
HEALTH CONCERNS THAT HAVE
RECENTLY BEEN IDENTIFIED- AS
WELL AS THE COST OF REQUIRING
THE CONSULTANT TO MAKE
RECOMMENDATIONS ON HOW TO
ADDRESS THESE CONCERNS. I THINK
MY- COLLEAGUES AT DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE MAY HAVE. BEEN INTENDING
TO MAKE SOME COMMENTS ON THIS OR
OTHER ITEMS- IN THIS. IN THIS
ISSUE THAT ACCIDENTALLY GOT
SKIPPED. THANK YOU. HI LANEY
SCHNEIDER DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
STATES CAITLYN- I'D LIKE TO
RESPOND TO THE RECOMMENDATIONS
SO AS FAR AS ADDRESSING THE
SCOPE AND PROTEST POTENTIAL
ADDITIONAL COSTS THERE IS THE
POSSIBILITY THAT THE FINAL
AMOUNT COULD BE SLIGHTLY HIGHER
OR LOWER. DEPENDING ON THE SCOPE
THAT'S FINALIZED EYES THE
DEPARTMENT ENGAGES BUT THE
CONTRACTOR- AND THE
ADMINISTRATION DOESN'T ARE TO BE
PLANNED TO PRECLUDE THE
CONSULTANT FROM CONSIDERING
DEPARTMENT PUBLIC HEALTH
CONCERNS WHEN MAKING A
RECOMMENDATION. WE REITERATE
THAT THE PURPOSE OF THE
ASSESSMENT AND ALTERNATE
RECOMMENDATION IS TO GENERATE
IDEAS ON THE BEST USE OF THE
SPACE TO CREATE ADDITIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES TO MEET THE NEEDS
OF THE INCARCERATED POPULATION.
SO WE HAVE LEFT IT VERY. RIGHT
UP. RIGHT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH I HAVE A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS- WITH REGARDS TO THE-
STATEWIDE BUDGET PACKAGE. HELLO
I'M SORRY I'M SORRY I DIDN'T SEE
YOUR HAND OKAY. GOOD AFTERNOON
INSTANT PAYMENT ON THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I JUST
WANTED TO SPEAK- BRIEFLY THE
UTILITIES AND WASTE REMOVL
FUNDING METHODOLOGY AND JUST
KNOW THAT THAT- THESE
METHODOLOGIES HAVEN'T BEEN
ADJUSTED- SINCE TWENTY TWELVE
TWENTY THIRTEEN FOR THE WASTE
REMOVAL IN TWENTY THIRTEEN
FOURTEEN FOR THE UTILITIES. AND
WHILE SINCE THAT TIME COST OF
GROWING EVEN WITH THE REDUCED
POPULATIONS SUCH AS IN TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THE
POPULATIONS CLOSE TO NINETY SIX
THOUSAND AND UTILITIES COSTS.
FAR EXCEEDED- BUDGETED AMOUNTS
SO WE JUST WANTED TO NOTE THAT
THAT- WE'RE LOOKING FOR MORE
CONSISTENT AND REASONABLE-
BUDGETING METHODOLOGY. THANK YOU
I'M SORRY THE- I GOT- I MISSED
YOU THERE- OKAY. I HAVE A COUPLE
OF QUESTIONS WITH REGARDS TO
THE- PLANNING A PROPOSAL THE
FUNDING FOR THE ADVANCE PLANNING
PROPOSAL. COULD THAT- BE USED TO
DEVELOP THE STRATEGY- THAT WE
HAVE BEEN. WE HAVE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT- WHO'S THAT MR LEAF OR
ANYONE YEAH THE- IT THAT THIS
THIS FUNDING IS TO DEVELOP A
BUDGET PACKAGE IS FOR SPECIFIC
CAPITAL OUTLAY PROPOSALS THAT
MAY BE- APPROVED TO- YOU'VE
REQUESTED AND FUTURE BUDGETS.
WELL ONE THING YOU COULD COVER
IS THE LONG TERM INFRASTRUCTURE
STRATEGY SO. AS YOU'VE HEARD
FROM OUR CONVERSATIONS HERE- TWO
MORE QUESTIONS- WHAT HAPPENS TO
OTHER FACILITIES OR AREAS THAT
HAVE BEEN PREVIOUSLY CLOSED OR
DECOMMISSION. ARE YOU TALKING
ABOUT- INSTITUTION SET OF
CLOTHES SUCH AS THE DUPLICATION-
INSTITUTION. AT ZERO WHOLE
FACILITY IN THE AREA YES. WELL
THE ONE THE WHOLE FACILITY IT IS
CLOSE- IT GOES INTO A WARM SHUT
DOWN- STATUS- WHICH INCLUDES A
SKELETON CREW TO- PERFORM
MINIMAL MAINTENANCE- ACTIVITIES
AND PROVIDE SECURITY AT THE
FACILITIES- TO- YOU KNOW
PREVENTS THE- DEGRADATION OF THE
FACILITY. TO AN EXTREME DEGREE
AND TO- PREVENTS IT FROM
BECOMING AN ATTRACTIVE NUISANCE
- WHAT IF THERE ARE PORTIONS OF
AN ACTIVE INSTITUTIONS THAT ARE-
THAT ARE CLOSE TO- DOES CONTINUE
TO BE A MAN'S HANDS- BY BY THE
INSTITUTION. OKAY AND THEN- ONE
LAST QUESTION IS- I WAS
INTERESTED TO SEE ON THE INMATE
WARD LABOR CONSTRUCTION- THE
PRIDE PROGRAM- HOW SUCCESSFUL DO
YOU SEE THAT WORKING AS FAR AS
MATCHING THOSE OF MEN AND WOMEN
TO- TO- WITH RESTORATION
EMPLOYMENT TAXES ACTUAL JOBS YOU
KNOW WHEN THEY ARE RELEASED-
WELL CERTAINLY- THAT THERE IS A
REHABILITATIVE COMPONENT FOR
THE- INMATE WORKERS AND- THEY
ARE LEARNING SKILLS THAT- THEY
CAN- BRING TO THEIR POST
INCARCERATION LINE. I DON'T HAVE
ANY STATS OR EXAMPLES BUT THAT
IS CERTAINLY A PART OF THE
PROGRAM. IF YOU COULD. DIG IN
AND- YOU KNOW PROVIDE THAT FOR
US I WOULD I WOULD REALLY BE
INTERESTED I THINK THAT'S SUCH
AN IMPORTANT PART. OF WHAT WE DO
IS TO PROVIDE THAT KIND OF
CONNECTION AND I UNDERSTAND
YOUR- CONNECTED WITH THE US
STATE BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL SO- IT WOULD BE
REALLY GOOD TO HAVE THAT KIND OF
INFORMATION AS TO YOUR SUCCESS.
WILL WILL DEVELOP THAT NONE ARE.
PUT TOGETHER SOME INFORMATION
FOR YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. OKAY COLLEAGUES ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS THANK YOU
NO OKAY AND THE LAST ISSUE IS
ISSUE FIVE IT'S ACTUALLY- BOMB
THE TRANSPORTATION. SEE
TRANSPORTATION IMPLEMENTATION OF
SB SIX SEVENTY ONE. GOOD
AFTERNOON SURE TO ROSALYN
SENATORS THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK HERE TODAY.
BY MITCH WEISS EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION. AS A
BRIEF BACKGROUND THE COMMISSION
IS AN INDEPENDENT STATE AGENCY
RESPONSIBLE RESPONSIBLE FOR
PROGRAMMING AND ALLOCATING
TRANSPORTATION FUNDS TO CAPITAL
PROJECTS. WE HAVE ELEVEN VOTING
COMMISSIONERS AND TWO NONVOTING
LEGISLATIVE EX OFFICIO
COMMISSIONERS ONE OF WHOM IS
SENATOR NEWMAN A STAFF OF ABOUT
THREE DOZEN. BEFORE I GET INTO
THIS PROPOSAL I WOULD JUST LIKE
TO NOTE THAT THE COMMISSION IS
VERY PLEASED TO SEE THE
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
SUCH A FOCUS OF THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET. AND APPLAUDS THE
GOVERNOR'S LEADERSHIP AND
PROPOSING SOLUTIONS TO MEET
CALIFORNIA'S DIVERSE
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
NEEDS. THE COMMISSION WELCOMES
THE OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE
COLLABORATING WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AND ADMINISTRATION
TO ENSURE THESE INVESTMENTS ARE
COORDINATED WITH THE
COMMISSION'S EXISTING PROGRAMS
AND ACCOUNTABILITY PROCESSES. TO
ENSURE THE TRANSPARENT EFFICIENT
TIMELY USE THESE FUNDS. THE ITEM
BEFORE YOU IT'S A BUDGET
PROPOSAL TO IMPLEMENT SENATE
BILL SIX SEVENTY ONE. WHICH
REQUIRES THE COMMISSION TO
DEVELOP A CLEAN FREE QUARTER
EFFICIENCY ASSESSMENT. THE
COMMISSION IS REQUESTING SEVEN
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS TO HIRE TO LIMITED TERM
POSITIONS AND X. EXECUTE A
ONETIME CONSULT CONTRACT. THE
CLEAN FREE CORRIDOR EFFICIENCY
ASSESSMENT WILL IDENTIFY FREIGHT
CORRIDORS AND INFRASTRUCTURE
NEEDED TO SUPPORT THE DEPLOYMENT
OF MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES. BY
CONSIDERING THE POTENTIAL FOR
EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS CHARGING
AND FUELING INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS
CONGESTION REDUCTION. ROAD
SAFETY RESILIENCY AND THE
IMPACTS ON NEIGHBORING KENYA X.
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MR WEISS ARE WE
WILL HAVE SOMEBODY FROM
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE PLEASE. I
UNDERSTAND EVEN CALLED PERMANENT
FINANCE I'M JUST NOT THAT WE
SUPPORT THE PROPOSALS PRESENTED. OKAY THE ALLELES OFFICE PLEASE
. AFTERNOON MANAGER AND MANY
MEMBERS THANK MINISTER
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE-
PRINCE BROKE OR WE HAVE NO
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS BUT I'M
HAPPY TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS.
OKAY MR NEWMAN. USE. YOU KNOW I
HAVE SIMPLY HAD THE LOOK ON YOUR
FACE. SO YES SIR MR WEISS NICE
TO SEE YOU IT'S A- I AM- IT'S MY
PLEASURE TO BE THE ONE OF THE
EXTRA FEW MEMBERS OF THE CDC.
THE ORIGINAL STAFF COMMENTS YOU
KNOW THE ORIGINAL ESTIMATE FOR.
THE COST FOR IMPLEMENTING SIX
THIRTY ONE WORD NINE HUNDRED
THOUSAND- THE BUDGET INCLUDES
SOMETHING LESS THAN THAT IF YOU
WOULD MIND SPEAKING TO THAT THAT
DELTA- AND THE PERSPECTIVE. THE
IMPACTS THAT NOT FULLY FUNDING
THE REQUEST MIGHT HAVE- SO-
YOU'RE CORRECT ORIGINAL FISCAL
ESTIMATE AT WHAT A FINE- WAS A
LITTLE BIT LARGER AND THIS
PROPOSAL WOULD FUND MORE LIMITED
SCOPE AND SO THERE ARE SOME CAST
THAT WE DON'T BELIEVE THE WORLD
WILL BE COMPLETING- THEY INCLUDE
THINGS LIKE- OBTAINING MORE
SPECIFIC LOCATION BASED TRUCK
MOVEMENT DATA. AND CREATING A
MAP- HYDROGEN STATIONS INCLUDING
RECOMMENDING A PRIORITIZATION OF
THE AREAS NEEDING STATIONS- BUT
THAT SO WE'RE WE'RE LOOKING AT
AT- SH LIGHTLY DOWNSTROKE EFFORT
THAN WE HAD ORIGINALLY THOUGHT
WHEN THAT BILL WAS. PROPOSED AND
I DO APPRECIATE THAT AND I WOULD
SAY- WITH RESPECT HYDROGEN MADAM
SURE DAD THINK- DO YOU KNOW THIS
THIS ONE COULD ARGUE THIS IS A
GOOD INVESTMENT- ALLOCATING
THESE FUNDS NOW. FOR DOING SOME
WORK THAT WE KNOW IS GOING TO BE
USEFUL RATHER THAN LATER SO.
PRECIADO THAT MR WATCH- AND I
NOTICE WE'RE GONNA HOLD US OPEN
BUT WE'LL- KEEP THIS MUCH ROOM
FOR. GREAT THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR. BRINGING THAT TO OUR
ATTENTION- LET'S SEE WE'RE GONNA
NOW MOVE INTO PUBLIC COMMENT
REGARDING ANY OF THE ISSUES AND
I'M SORRY THANK YOU MR WEISS AND
EVERYONE WHO SPOKE WITH ALL
QUESTIONS- AND DISCUSSIONS HAVE
NOW ENDED WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON
TO A PUBLIC COMMENT REGARDING
ANY OF THE ISSUES THAT WE RAISED
TODAY. AS A REMINDER TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS
844-291-6364 AND THE ACCESS CODE
IS FIVE EIGHT SIX THREE NINE ONE
SEVEN. DUE TO CONSTRAINTS
REGARDING THE LENGTH OF HEARINGS
TECHNOLOGY CONSIDERATIONS AND
CLEANING PROTOCOLS UP WE WILL
INSTITUTE- WE MAY IS A TWO TIME
LIMITS ON TESTIMONY TODAY I'M
GOING TO ASK THAT EACH MEMBER OF
THE PUBLIC PROVIDING COMMENT
KEEP THEIR REMARKS TO WITHIN
MAXIMUM ONE MINUTE UP NOW LET'S
BEGIN WITH ANY WITNESSES HERE IN
THE ROOM. SAYING NONE AFTER THE
WITNESSES- LET'S SEE MODERATOR
WOULD YOU PLEASE PROMPT THE
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT AND IF YOU WOULD
LET US KNOW HOW MANY. ARE
WAITING IN THE QUEUE. YES
CURRENTLY WE HAVE ONE IN QUEUE
FOR PUBLIC COMMENT- AS A
REMINDER IF YOU DO WANT TO MAKE
A PUBLIC COMMENT YOU CAN PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME ON
YOUR PHONE. YOU WILL ONLY NEED
TO PRESS IT ONCE ONCE YES
PRESSED OPERATOR WILL GIVE YOU
YOUR LINE NUMBER. AND IT LOOKS
LIKE ONE OTHER PERSON LINED UP
HE'S GOT TO SO FAR THE FIRST ONE
WILL COME FROM THE LINE OF THE
TWENTY FOUR PART PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ALL YOU HAVE TO AFTERNOON
WHEN I PUBLISHED MY NAME IS THE
BRAND B. R. I'M PROBABLY. FROM
SALINAS CALIFORNIA CURRENTLY THE
DEPUTY DIRECTOR WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LARGELY YOU CAN.
DIRECTOR I'M HERE TODAY TO SPEAK
ABOUT ISSUE NUMBER ONE. SOMEONE
WAS FORMALLY CARPETED DIRECT
EXPERIENCE IN BOTH GIVEN HOW
ANNABELLE I'M INTERESTED IN ALSO
CONTACT NUMBERS PEOPLE CURRENTLY
INCARCERATED IN LOCAL
FACILITIES. I'M WELL AWARE OF
THE ABUSE AND NEGLECT JAPANESE
FACILITY. DEMOCRAT HIGHLIGHTED
JUST HOW MUCH. THEY CALL THEIR
SHARE OF PROBATION AND A BEAUTY
PFL. UNINCORPORATED LOVED ONE.
IF YOU HAD HOLD STAKEHOLDER
ACCOUNTABLE AND OFFICE THE LAW.
STAKEHOLDERS IF YOU HAVE
POLITICAL POWER THAT PREPAY
REPEAT TO YOU FOR THE PART OF
PEOPLE ACROSS UNDER ITS WATCH
INSTEAD QUIETLY AND POLITE
COLLAB WITH LONG OFFICIALS
DECIDED THAT ISSUES. I MEAN COME
AGAIN. THE POPE NOT WORK NO
REPORTS THE ALLEY OFF HAVE
HIGHLIGHTED IN AROUND WEEKEND.
BREAD WHAT DISBURSEMENT OF GRANT
. DEBORAH DO YOU THINK HE PICK
UP STANCE ON ISSUES ON COMPLYING
. WHAT AID IF YOU DON'T HAVE
BEEN POWERED EIGHT IF YOU CAN
AND SHOULD DO FAR MORE TO
HIGHLIGHT PROBLEMS I. THIRTEEN
PERFECT BOAR IS COMPOSED OF LOW
LAW LONG. THAT AND- BALANCE
FIGURE MAKING COPIES ABOUT A CAN
YOU CAN'T PUT THEM CALL. IT IS
TIME TO CHANGE COMPOSITION THIS
CRITICAL BLOG AND EXPAND THE
OKAY OF MUCH. STAKEHOLDER DIVERS
UP MATTER. IN ORDER TO BRING TO
MY NEEDED BY TO THE FORCE. THAT
I WANT TO READ YOU. ABOUT
BROTHERS B. HE- THE CONCERN OF
BEYOND OF FINDING THE STAFF
READERSHIP I THINK IF YOU HAVE A
WHOLE OUR GOAL BLOCK THE
OVERSIGHT AND UNTIL. THE ALLEY
OLD RECOMMENDATIONS ARE
INSTITUTED WE SHOULD NOT.
EXPANDABLE GEO THANK YOU. THANK
YOU FOR. IN MODERATOR ANYMORE-
PARTICIPANTS. YES CURRENTLY
YOU'LL HAVE SIX MORE IN Q. THE
NEXT LINE IS TWENTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MMHM. HELLO HELLO. CAN
YOU ALL HEAR ME YES GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON BUT MANY MEMBERS
MY NAME IS OFFLINE AND WORDS
NUMBER STARTING OVER IN
RIVERSIDE COUNTY SPEAKING ON
ISSUE NUMBER ONE. I'D LIKE TO
ECHO THE COMMENTS MADE BY THE
PREVIOUS SPEAKER OR- EXPRESS THE
NEEDS OF THOSE WE ARE TRYING TO
CONNECT HM. IT'S CLEAR TO US
THAT THE BEST WAY TO IMPROVE THE
CONDITIONS FACED BY INCARCERATED
PEOPLE IT'S JOHN CORRESPONDENT
OUR CURRENT UNDERSTANDING BACK
DID NOT. NEED TAKE CARE OF THEM
FOR. CRIMINAL I MEAN IT'S NOT
VERY. I'D LIKE TO SHARE ABOUT
HOW TO BE A YEAH IT'S A GREAT
THE BACK. PART IF YOU COULD
REVERT BACK. THE START OF THE
KIND OF TO YOUR AGO THE ONE
HUNDRED MEMBER ARE YOU JEALOUS
AND THEIR LOVED ONES REPORTER
IN. MISSIONS YEAH THE- OKAY IS
NOT BOX HAD. I'M NOT A CARE
NUMBER SO IN. ON THE REVERSE
SHERIFF'S. FOR HE WOULD NOT BE
READY. AND I DON'T FIND
GRADUATED DESERVE IT OKAY. YOU
DON'T HAVE TO BE AT THE ABOUT
THE JOB PER MONTH. YES HE'S THE
ONLY CONDUCT AND THEN BY SEVERAL
MONTHS AFTER THE BIRTH OF THE-
AND IT WAS A NON THE SHARES
DEPARTMENT THE HEART OF GIVE THE
PART THANKS FOR YOU. RECORDS
WELCOME THAT THEY NOT THE CARD
THAT WE LIVE IN THAT. DON'T EVEN
A CREDIT SETTING AND TO BE A
FIFTY.
MARK AND BACK AGAIN AND NO
PASSPORT TO IMPROVE THE JOB
CONDITIONS. WELL THOSE NUMBERS
ARE EVEN OUT OF THE RIVER THANK
JOKE ABOUT OTHER FACILITIES
ACROSS THE STATE THE OWNER OF A
PROPERTY INSURANCE. YOU CAN'T.
JUMP ON THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR CALLING MODERATE
WORK BUT JUST GIVE US A SECOND
HERE. WE HAVE TO DO THAT QUORUM
. SO MENEM BACK BILL. A SENATOR
ALSO HERE THAT ARE GROWTH.
SENATOR CORTEZ IN SENATOR NEWMAN
. THANK YOU NOW WE'RE OFFICIAL-
MODERATOR YOU CAN CONTINUE WITH
OUR PARTICIPANTS. THE NEXT COMIC
COMES FROM LINE TWENTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS ELIZABETH FRASER I'M
A MEMBER OF SHOWING UP FOR
RACIAL JUSTICE SEARCH THE AREA A
MEMBER ORGANIZATION OF
CALIFORNIANS UNITED FOR
RESPONSIBLE BUDGET AND I'M
CALLING REGARDING ISSUE NUMBER
TWO. AND SENATOR NEWMAN- I
THOUGH I SHARE YOUR FRUSTRATION
WITH REGARDS TO THE MASTER PLAN
AND THE SUPPLEMENTAL REPORTING
LANGUAGE I DO REMEMBER LAST
YEAR'S CONVERSATIONS REGARDING
PRISON CLOSURE AND IN FACT FOR
YEARS NOW I HAVE HEARD THIS
COMMITTEE AND YOUR COLLEAGUES ON
THE ASSEMBLY SIDE ASK CDC ARE
FOR A PLAN. SO THAT YOU CAN MAKE
THE RESPONSIBLE DECISIONS THAT
YOU'RE TASKED WITH THIS IS A
WHOLLY REASONABLE REQUEST AND
YEAR AFTER YEAR THE PCR HAD
REFUSED AND HALF THE BALCONIES
DEMAND. IS KICKING THE CAN. AND
IT'S UNACCEPTABLE. I WILL LAST
WEEK REPRESENT. WAS JUST OVER
NINETY TWO THOUSAND LEVEL THAT
WE HAVEN'T SEEN SINCE NINETEEN
NINETY ONE WHEN OUR STATE
OPERATED TWELVE FEWER PRISONS
AND SPENT TWELVE BILLION DOLLARS
LESS ANNUALLY ON CORRECTIONS
THAN WE DO TODAY. AT THE
RESIDENCE IN TOPIC THAT RESIDENT
HARDWARE I RELY ON YOU TO MAKE
RESPONSIBLE DECISIONS ON HOW TO
SPEND OUR TAX DOLLARS. AT THE J.
OR G. TO DENY ALL OVER
INFRASTRUCTURE REQUESTS AND I
URGE YOU TO WORK WITH
CALIFORNIANS UNITED FOR
RESPONSIBLE BY JET AND A DOCTOR
THOUGHT PULLED UP A LOGICAL PLAN
FOR CRITICAL YOUR MESQUITE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR CALLING
NEXT PLEASE. COMMENT COMES FROM
THE LINE TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON BRIAN
GOLDSTINE WITH THE CENTER ON
JUVENILE AND CRIMINAL JUSTICE
I'D LIKE TO SPEAK ON ISSUE ONE
JAIL OVERSIGHT I WANT TO THANK
THE CHAIR AND MEMBERS FOR THIS
CRITICAL DISCUSSION WE ENGAGED
WITH THE PSC FOR YEARS AND WE
BELIEVE THAT THE BSG FAILED TO
ADDRESS. MATTERS OF LIFE AND
DEATH INSIDE JAILS AND JUVENILE
FACILITIES. WE AGREE WITH MANY
OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS BY THE L.
A. L. STATE AUDITOR AND
WITNESSES WHO PRESENTED TODAY.
BUT THE BSE SEES ISSUES AREN'T
SIMPLY A MATTER OF BUDGETS OR
STATUTORY AUTHORITY. TELL YOUR
AGENCY AND THEIR LEADERSHIP J.
O. REGULATIONS ARE WEAK AND THEY
DON'T ALIGN WITH NATIONAL BEST
PRACTICES AND THE BSE C. MUST BE
INDEPENDENT AGENCIES THEY
OVERSEE. FINALLY THE PSC'S
THIRTEEN PERSON BOARD MUST
INCLUDE THE NECESSARY COMMUNITY
STAKE HOLDERS AND EXPERTS WE
KEEP ALL CALIFORNIANS SAFE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU FOR CALLING
SHADED NEXT PLEASE. OUR NEXT
COMMENT COMES FROM ONE TWENTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON I'M SPEAKING ON ITEM
ONE JAIL OVERSIGHT MY NAME'S
KELSEY READING I MEAN YOU CAN
ORGANIZE THEIR WITH THE HUMBOLDT
COUNTY TRANSITION AGE YOUTH
COLLABORATION AND ALSO THE CHAIR
OF THE HUMBLE COUNTY JUVENILE
JUSTICE AND DELINQUENCY
PREVENTION COMMISSION BUT I'M
HERE SPEAKING TODAY AS AN
INDIVIDUAL- I'M BASED ON MY
EXPERIENCE WORKING WITH YOUNG
PEOPLE ABOUT THE EXPERIENCE IN
THE JUSTICE SYSTEM. AND WITHIN
LOCAL GOVERNMENT I UNDERSTAND
HOW VITAL IT IS TO HAVE
COMMUNITY STAKEHOLDERS ON BOARD
TO MAKE DECISIONS THAT IMPACT
THEM AND THEIR PEERS SUCH AS THE
SEC. THESEC REALLY NEEDS TO
EXPAND THE REPRESENTATION OF
COMMUNITY STAKEHOLDERS AND
SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTS ON THE
AGENCY'S THIRTEEN BOARD-
CURRENTLY THEY ONLY HAVE LAW
ENFORCEMENT I THANK OUR
ADMINISTRATOR FOR CORRECTIONAL
FACILITIES FOR RENTAL
FACILITIES- OR SHARE YOUR
PROBATION OFFICERS ONE CHIEF AND
ONE OF THE REPRESENTATIVES AND
THE S. IF YOU REALLY NEED TO
EXPAND. THIS BOARD COMPOSITION
TO INCLUDE SUBJECT MATTER
EXPERTS AS WELL AS THE MOST
IMPACTED BY THESE BOARDS
DECISION MAKING IT'S ALSO A GOOD
REPRESENTATION OF COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATION MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS AND CRUMBLING CARS
RATED PEOPLE AND YOU. AND COREY-BROWN- IN THE U. R. ET I'D GET
THE BOARD THAT DIRECT MY WORK
THEY. SAY NOTHING FOR US WITHOUT
US THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
CALLING NEXT PLAY. NEXT QUESTION
COMES FROM THE LINE OF TWENTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
NAME IS MELISSA CAMACHO CHIMED
IN WITH THE EASY ARE YOU CUTTING
CALIFORNIA AND SPEAKING ON ISSUE
ONE. IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE FIFTY
FIVE PEOPLE DIED IN LA COUNTY
JAIL. MORE THAN A PERSON A WEEK
THE NUMBER OF BOTH BREATHTAKING
AND RECORD BREAKING THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
TRACKS LA COUNTY JAIL DEATHS
GOING BACK TO TWO THOUSAND FIVE
YOU KNOW THE LAST SIXTEEN YEARS
LA COUNTY HAS NEVER HAD MORE.
THAN FIFTY BACK INTO LAST YEAR.
IT RAISED ON THE TODAY. THE CARD
SAN DIEGO EMAIL ACCOUNT.
INADEQUATE SAFETY CHECK AND KNOW
BASIC STANDARDS FOR SICK CALL.
THE MINIMUM TENDER CONDUCTED
ASIANS ARE NOT PROTECTING THE
LIVES OF THOSE IN JAIL. I AGREE
WITH MANY OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS
TODAY INCLUDING REQUIRING THE
SEC MEMBERSHIP BECAUSE OF
MEDICAL AND MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS ADVOCATES AND
PEOPLE WHO DIDN'T PREVIOUSLY
INCARCERATED IN JAIL. TERRY TO
BRING THE FTC STANDARD LINE OF
BEST PRACTICES AS AN EXAMPLE
DURING THE LAST REVISION CYCLE
FOR THE ADULT STANDARDS. THE ESC
REFUSED TO REQUIRE ANY MINIMUM
TIME OUTDOORS IN THE FRESH AIR.
HE ADDED L. E. O. IS ON THE
COMMITTEE STATED THAT THIS WAS
JUST NOT POSSIBLE WITHOUT
PROVIDING ANY EVIDENCE AND
IGNORING THE DIRECTIONS AND THE
GOVERNOR TO ENSURE STANDARDS ARE
CONSISTENT WITH NATIONAL BEST
PRACTICES. MEMBERSHIP ON THESE
COMMITTEES MATTERS PEOPLE WHO
HAVE EXPERIENCED INCARCERATION
YOU NEED TO BE NEED TO HAVE
THEIR EXPERTISE OKAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATE
YOUR CALLING NEXT PLEASE. NEXT
COMMENT WILL COME FROM WIND
THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS
EMILY HARRIS I AM THE POLICY
DIRECTOR WITH THE OLYMPIC KERR
CENTER FOR HUMAN RIGHTS AND I'D
LIKE TO SPEAK ON ITEM ONE TWO
THREE AND FOUR. OKAY KEEP MY
COMMENTS BRIEF- HONOR HAS BEEN
WORKING IN ALAMEDA COUNTY FOR
MANY YEARS- FOCUSING ON THE FACT
WE HAD JAIL. THERE'S BEEN OVER
FIFTY SIX DEATHS IN CUSTODY
SINCE TWENTY FOURTEEN. AND WE
BELIEVE THAT THE BORDER STATE
AND COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS ROLE
CAN NEVER BE HAVING LAW
ENFORCEMENT OVERSEAS LAW
ENFORCEMENT- EXPANDING THE SEC'S
ALONG IN THIS TYPE OF OVERSIGHT
YOU'RE JUST GOING TO CONTINUE TO
BE HERE LIKE. PRISONS AND JAILS
ARE BY NATURE ARE DANGEROUS AND
HARMFUL TO OUR LOVED ONES. AND
WE HAVE TO MOVE THAT THE
COMMITTEE WAS TALKING ABOUT
TODAY TOWARD INVESTMENT OUTSIDE
OF LOCKING PEOPLE UP AND INTO
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES. I TWO
THREE AND FOUR- THE MASTER PLAN
IS BASICALLY OUTRAGEOUS I READ
THE WHOLE THING- AND IT FEELS AS
THOUGH IT'S AN INSTANT SUPPORT
INSUBORDINATION OF THE REQUESTED
THIS COMMITTEE TO MAKE A POINT.
AND YET WHEN I THINK ABOUT IT OF
COURSE THE INFRASTRUCTURE IS
CRUMBLING IN ARE PRESENTED IN
THE SAME THE INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
AROUND FOR FIFTY YEARS- AND THE
SUPPORT BEHIND LOCKING UP BLACK
AND BROWN PEOPLE IS ALSO
CURRENTLY. AND HAS NEVER BEEN TO
MAKE THEIR JOBS ACT OBSOLETE
THERE WILL IS TO IMPRISON PEOPLE
AND THAT'S WHAT THEY WANT TO
CONTINUE TO DO SO THEY'RE GOING
TO CONTINUE TO DRAG THEIR FEET
AND GET THE LEGISLATURE RUN
AROUND UNTIL WE URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO PLEASE WORK WITH-
COMMUNITY MEMBERS INCLUDING- WE
HAVE A REPORT. THAT LISTS THE
TEN PRESENTS THAT WERE
RECOMMENDED TO US BY OVER TWO
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED PEOPLE IN
CALIFORNIA PRISON THEY HELPED US
IDENTIFY WHICH PRESENTS NEED TO
BE CLOSED. AND WE IMAGINE THAT
THEIR LIVED EXPERIENCE FROM
BEING IN THOSE PRESENT WILL BE
VERY USEFUL. THIS COMMITTEE
MAKES A DECISION ABOUT CLOSING
THE INFRASTRUCTURE FOR HELPING A
PRESIDENT WE KNOW THAT THE
DECISIONS MADE TODAY ARGAN AND-
AFFECT THE NEXT FIFTY YEARS IN
CALIFORNIA WE CAN HAVE FIFTY
MORE YEARS. OF VIOLENT
INFRASTRUCTURE OR WE CAN BE
MOVING TO CLOSE THESE
INSTITUTIONS AND. WE HOPE TO
WORK WITH THE COMMITTEE TO DO
THAT THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. MODERATOR NEXT PARTICIPANT
. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU DO HAVE A
COMMENT YOU CAN PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME- RIGHT NOW OR
- A COMMENT IN Q. IS THIRTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M
THIRTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
AVAILABLE OR DEFEND I'M AN
ORGANIZER WITH ELLA BAKER CENTER
FOR HUMAN RIGHTS AS WELL AS
CRITICAL RESISTANCE IN OAKLAND
BOTH MEMBER ORGANIZATION FOR
CALIFORNIANS UNITED FOR
RESPONSIBLE BUDGET I'M ALSO
CALLING IN RESPONSE TO ISSUES
CONCERNING THE ART MASTER PLAN
ANNUAL REPORT I APPRECIATE THE
COMMITTEE'S COMMITMENT EACH YEAR
THE QUESTION THAT THE DVR WILL
BE ESSENTIAL INFORMATION TO
DETERMINE A LONG TERM STRATEGY
AROUND INFRASTRUCTURE AND
SPENDING. I ALSO WAS SHOCKED
THAT THE DVD ARE FORECAST THE
NEED FOR NEARLY FOUR BILLION
DOLLARS FOR INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECTS IN THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE MASTER PLAN AND WILL REPORT
INCLUDING MAJOR PROJECT THAT
EVERYTHING WILL BE PRESENTED BY
CALIFORNIA'S PRISON POPULATION
DROPPING BY NEARLY 20% OVER THE
PAST YEAR I'VE BEEN EDITOR
DOURADO POINTED OUT ACROSS THE
YARD THERE ARE NEARLY TWENTY
THOUSAND BEDS NOT BEING USED
YES. YARD BUDGET CONTINUES TO
BALLOON FOURTEEN POINT TWO
BILLION DOLLARS IN CARTS ARE
OFFENDING IS NOT A BLUEPRINT FOR
CALIFORNIA FISCAL HEALTH THE
HUMANE PHYSICALLY RESPONSIBLE
INTO THE LISTING HERE IS NOT
THAT THE MORE FATALITIES ON
CONSTRUCTION PROJECT TO
ACCOMMODATE OUR ELDERS IN PRISON
BUT THE REDUCED THE ELDER PRISON
POPULATION THE COMPASSIONATE
RELEASES AND MORE PRISON CULTURE
I HOPE THE COMMITTEE WILL CALL
FOR A JOINT BUT BY OVERSIGHT
HEARING ON THE CPR
INFRASTRUCTURE REPORT THAT
AND PACKED BOOKS. INCLUDING
REPRESENTATIVES FROM CRICKET YOU
GONNA PEOPLE FIND FOR PRISON.
CLOSURE REPORT THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MODERATOR NEXT PARTICIPANT.
EXPERTS IS NINE THIRTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS OLIVIA GRIFFIN
EILENBERG CURB CALIFORNIANS
UNITED FOR A RESPONSIBLE BUDGET
I'M FROM LONG BEACH CALIFORNIA
IN RESPONSE TO ISSUES TO A VERY
MUCH APPRECIATED SENATOR NEWMAN
SENATOR DERIVED. BUT WHEN IT
COMES TO FEATURE A BLACK OF
PLANNING REGARDING PRISON
CLOSURE AND CONSOLIDATION
CHALLENGING FEATURES CALL METRIC
ENCLOSURES ARE QUOTE POINT IN
TIME DECISION. DESPITE THE S. R.
S. R. L. TO BE BACK TO
INCORPORATE POTENTIAL PRISON
CLOSURE OPPORTUNITY EACH INTO
INFRASTRUCTURE PLANNING EACH
TEACHER HAD LOCAL INTERPRETER
CLOSURE OR CONSOLIDATION. IN
ADDITION TO THE POPULATION
REDUCTION DATA THAT COULD ALLOW
IT TO START PLANNING FOR PRISON
CLOSURE WHICH IS FIFTY YEARS OF
PROVED EVIDENT BY THE HARMS EASY
ARTS COLLEGE AGE AND DELIBERATE
INDIFFERENCE TO KOBE. IN THE
STREET ONE OF THE CARS ARE GOOD
PEOPLE AND WOMEN COULD
HORRIFICALLY CONDITIONS AT
MISTER SPECTER AT YOUR RISK IS
GREG EARLIER IN REFERENCE TO
ISSUE ONE SH I DEPART FROM THAT
HEARING IN PCR MASTER PLANNED.
PCR DOESN'T CONSIDER THE
ADEQUATE NEED TO CONSIDER PRISON
CLOSURE AND CONSOLIDATION THESE
ISSUES WOULD HAVE BEEN FIXED BY
NOW IF IT WAS TRULY THINK YOU
CASH PRIORITY WHICH MEANS THAT
MORE FUNDING IS NOT GOING TO
CHANGE THEIR- PLANNING FOR A
HEALTHIER AND SAFER CALIFORNIA
NOT A- POINT IN TIME DECISION WE
OWE IT TO IMPACTED COMMUNITIES
IN TOWN TO BECOME A LEADER
CENTERED AROUND PRISONS. TO
DEVELOP PLANS TO SHIFT. IN A
VOLUNTEER BASED FUTURES FOR
CALIFORNIA I URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO RESPECT ALL
INFRASTRUCTURE REQUEST IN ADOPT
A PLAN FOR PRISON CLOSURE BY
WORKING WITH GROUPS LIKE
CALIFORNIANS UNITED FOR
RESPONSIBLE BUDGET. PLANS IN
PLACE WHICH IS THE PEOPLE
QUICKER COOKING. CLOSURE THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR JOINING US. MODERATE NEXT
PARTICIPANT. THE LAST DISCOUNT
HAVING IS AND MY NUMBER SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU- WELL
I'M I'M A COORDINATOR AT THE CAR
STREET SACRAMENTO AND A MEMBER
OF THE CURRENT COALITION. I LIKE
TO SPEAK ON ITEM ONE AND Q. THAT
FIRST RECORDING JAIL OVERSIGHT-
DOCUMENT A COUNTY JAIL
CONDITIONS CONTINUE TO BLATANTLY
DISREGARD HUMAN LIFE. I'VE
SPOKEN WITH DOZENS OF THE PEOPLE
INSIDE. WE'RE NOT WITH BASIC
CLEANING SUPPLIES AND CONTINUE
TO BE EXPOSED TO COVET NINETEEN
ABSOLUTE DESTRUCTION OF OUR
LOCAL JAIL THAT THAT. THAT
KILLED PEOPLE HERE ALMOST WEEKLY
. BACKGROUND COUNTY HAD THE
WORST TRANSPARENCY IN THE STATE
WHEN IT COMES TO REPORTING COPA
DATA SHARE- INSURANCE DOC
BACKSEAT DATA EVEN THOUGH SURE
STOP OR REQUIRED TO BE TESTED
THEY ARE NOT REQUIRED BEING
REQUIRED TO REPORT THEIR RESULTS
. RECENTLY STARTED- BECAUSE ONE
OF THE WORST OUTBREAKS BETWEEN-
THE PANDEMIC- AND I'D ALSO LIKE
TO NOTE- THAT INVESTING AND
BUILDING MENTAL HEALTH JAIL DID
NOT ADDRESS THE ROOT CAUSE OF
CONDITIONS THAT CONTINUE TO
SPARK LOST IT YOU'RE ON P.
DEFICIENT BUT- CAN HE JOKED
STATEWIDE. AND HAVING A LOVED
ONE INCARCERATED IN COUNTY JAILS
WHILE EXPERIENCING A MENTAL
HEALTH CRISIS HAS CONFIRMED FOR
ME ON A PERSONAL LEVEL- THE
MAJORITY OF LOCAL CONTENT TO
CREATE REQUIREMENTS OUTLINED
THAT. JAIL STAFF PROCEDURES AND
PROTOCOLS AND CULTURE BETTER THE
TRUE CAUSES THAT INHUMANE AND
UNCONSTITUTIONAL. AND YOUR
CONDITION. ISN'T THAT RIGHT IT
COMES TO STATE LEVEL PRESENT
ISSUE TO REGARDING THE C. D. C.
R. MASTER PLAN- I JUST LIKE TO.
SAY WE REALLY NEED TO STOP
INVESTING IN QUICKER THAN C. D.
C. R. I HAVE NEVER FELT IT
MISSION- AND WASTED BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS THAT WHAT. BUT NEVER
MAKE PRESENT HEALTHY SAFE OR
HUMANE. DID YOU SEE OUR FOUR
BILLION DOLLAR PROJECTED
SPENDING FOR INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECTS AND THEIR- TWENTY
TWENTY ONE MAR A MASTER PLANNED-
INCLUDED MAJOR PROJECTS THAT
EVERY. SINGLE PERSON WHICH IS A
CLEAR CONTRADICTION IN THE LONG
TERM GOALS OF THE LEGISLATURE
AND MULTIPLE CALLS FROM YOUR
COMMITTEES FOR CDC ARE TO CREATE
A PLAN FOR PRISON CLOSURE TO
GUIDE YOUR DECISION MAKING.
AROUND FUTURE. INFRASTRUCTURE
REPAIR PROJECTS. COMPLETELY
HONEST. AND I ARE THAT I FOR YOU
ALL REJECT ALL AND INVESTMENT
DATE BECAUSE- I ALSO URGE THE
COMMITTEE TO. ENSURE EFFORTS
THAT PEOPLE PLAN FOR PRISON
CLOSURE WHICH WE CREATED WITH
INPUT FROM THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
INSIDE CALIFORNIA STATE PRISONS.
TO CREATE A LIST OF PRIORITIES
PREVENT CLOSURE- PRIME. THANK
YOU FOR CALLING. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR CALLING MODERATOR NEXT
PARTICIPANT. SURE THERE ARE NO
OTHERS IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME BUT
ONCE AGAIN THAT IS ONE THEN ZERO
FOR A PUBLIC COMMENT. ANYONE
WANTS TO PARTICIPATE THE PUBLIC
COMMENT PLEASE FOLLOW THE
INSTRUCTIONS. MADAM CHAIR WE DO
NOT HAVE ANY IN Q. OKAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MODERATOR THANK
YOU TO EVERYONE FOR YOUR
PATIENCE AND COOPERATION THANK
YOU TO ALL THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
CALLED IN TODAY FOR PUBLIC
TESTIMONY IF YOU WERE NOT ABLE
TO TESTIFY OR YOU WANT TO.
SUBMIT FURTHER COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING YOU CAN
DO SO- ON OUR WEBSITE YOUR
COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS ARE
IMPORTANT TO US WE WANT TO
INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY IN THE
OFFICIAL HEARING RECORDS THANK
YOU AGAIN THANK YOU TO MY
COLLEAGUES THANK YOU TO OUR
CONSULTANT MISS BACK BILL
EVERYONE HERE WHO MADE THIS ALL
POSSIBLE WE APPRECIATE YOU VERY
MUCH. THIS MEETING IS NOW
ADJOURNED.